foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Fairfax county is now in session the
animal Penny astronauts
all right good morning all right are you
ready for the jury today or do we have
any preliminary matters
okay if you want to approach with the
exhibits
which ones do you have for me
okay what number are they
all right are we ready for the jury okay
thank you
foreign
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right are we ready to
continue with the witness on deposition
yes your honored the remaining portion
of the deposition video of Aaron fellati
will uh include the questioning by
Council for Mr dapp all right thank you
foreign
do you have any professional
responsibility to report or document
suspective physical abuse of one of your
patients
if
I am
if I witness or find out information of
domestic
or child abuse yes
so what is that responsibility
need to notify
um
superiors of the information I was
provided with
when did you first meet this heard
I believe it was the end of
excuse me hang on one sec I have it here
I'm just looking at my nursing notes
um
it looks like August 27 2014.
okay so uh can we please pull up uh the
nursing notes which I believe our
uh okay um I'd like to while we have
this document up I'd like to go through
this this section that's called client
history do you see what I'm referring to
was the information in this paragraph
self-reported to you by Miss harder
I just have a quick moment to review
that and then I can answer that question
certainly thank you
so to answer that question I believe
this was
information given to me from miss her
I'm not positive but I can say that
anytime I refer or begin a sentence with
client states
or client reports those I can confirm
you know I I received that information
from the client
as far as in totality I would assume
most information came from Miss heard
but I can't rule out that I didn't get
any information from the treating
physician incorporation either
and I think you
would this information have been relayed
to you at that birth meeting with Miss
heard
this information
if if it was information I received from
Dr Kipper I would have had that
information probably prior to meeting
her but any time that I said States and
I can confirm that I got that
information I would assume that it was
sometime within the first day or two of
meeting her because I usually
take a client history when I meet a
client
put on a couple more sentences it says
Ah reports history of substance abuse
including an addiction to cocaine and
liquor
CTU client reports abstaining from
cocaine for a couple years but was
unable to report exact things can you
see what uh that's
do you see that where I'm referring to
yes I see that and that's something that
you would have written
yes okay and
um
this is also information that you
believe misheard would have reported
directly to you again I don't have
specific recollection of this but I
would have to refer to my notes that
says the client reports it so
the assumption would be made that she
provided me with that information
so it says it goes on to say CT does not
smoke cigarettes she reports consuming
one to three glasses of red wine
each day do you see that yes
um and again this is um based off of
your node something that Miss heard
reported to you correct
again I don't recall
the specifics of that I would refer
again that
in that particular sentence you're
referring to I used the verbiage of she
reports meaning misheard report so I
would make the assumption that she
reported that information to me
um in the time that misheard was your
patient do you recall seeing her
consuming
yes
is this from self-report of one to three
glasses of red wine each day consistent
with your recollection
I don't recall her
drinking red wine every time I saw her
so I I can't confirm
each time I saw her she would drink one
to three glasses I
I don't recall her drinking every time I
saw her
did you ever see Miss herd appear
intoxicated from drinking alcohol
I don't recall her being
intoxicated
okay so moving on to the next sentence
here it says she reports of familial
history of substance abuse abuse both
mother and father have abused and become
dependent on stimulants meth amphetamine
opiates and alcohol
did I read that correctly
yes and the the she here it refers to
Miss Hertz
that's correct okay
um so this is also something that Mr
reported to you as far as your notes
reflect
again I don't have specific recollection
of this uh it appears that she did
report that
but I don't remember
um so
a couple sentences later here it says
client admits to a his to history of
anxiety eating disorder attention
deficit disorder bipolar disorder
codependence issues and occasional
insomnia do you see that sentence
yes and based off of this note and
specifically the language that says
client and Men
um you believe that this is something
that Miss heard would have reported to
you
as you stated because it says client
admits I would make that assumption
um what do you recall Miss hurt saying
about her history of anxiety issues
I don't recall specifics uh
as I stated earlier in the morning I
remember a general anxiety with many
issues
in her life
what do you recall miss her telling you
about uh code her codependence issues
I have vague memory of discussing
codependence issues within previous
relationships I couldn't give you
specifics on that it's I just sort of
have a
vague memory of discussing that
do you have any non-specific
Recollections of misheard being
anger or enraged very then that time
that I spoke about in London 2014 I
didn't specifically Witness
anger and rage
on the next sentence here says her mood
has been
labile is that am I pronouncing that
correct
so first of all what does that mean
emotional availability is
typically when emotions swing on a
pendulum you know for example you may
see someone
very sad at one moment and quickly
transition to extreme happiness it sort
of swings from
like I said sort of a pendulum
and did you ever person in the time that
you treated miss her did you ever
personally witness this type of
emotional ability
I don't recall specifically
okay
[Music]
um
the next sentence says client expressed
concern to husband and Dr Kipper that
she's nervous about being alone while
husband is working on movie set in
London and express she has difficulty
dealing with feelings and insecurity and
jealousy when not in the presence of her
husband did I read that right
um
do you
um recall learning this during your um
initial meeting with Miss hard
I don't recall learning this during the
initial meeting but again the
when I initially met Ms heard and Mr
doubt it was
fairly brief because then after that we
traveled
to London
so I don't recall if I learned of this
instantaneously or if that was
gathered you know throughout the next
day or two spending time with her
um
description of misheard having feelings
of insecurity and jealousy would not in
the presence of Mr Duff is that
consistent with your recollection
when you were treating this heard
you wouldn't say all the time that was
an issue uh I have a vague sense of
those issues popping up throughout the
years but I wouldn't say that that was a
constant theme
but you do have Recollections of that
being an issue at some time while you
were treating it I would say that's a
fair statement
go to the
um entry for August 29th 29 2014.
okay so in this side I'd like to direct
your attention in this section that
starts with 23.45
and specifically the first sentence it
says client RN and Debbie RN went to
dinner together you see that thank you
um
and wrn is is Debbie Lloyd is that
correct
client verbalizes feelings of confusion
as she feels fiance would like her to
decrease slash eliminate acting career
and stay home
see that
do you remember having this specific
conversation with Miss heard
I don't remember specifically but I do
have a general
recollection
no I don't recall specifics
did you ever have any um discussions
with Mr depth concern
Ed
herds
um acting career
I have a sort of vague General
memory of discussing that before
as to specific details like don't think
I can provide you with specifics but
it sounds familiar
did you ever have the impression that Mr
Depp wanted miss her to stop her and her
acting career I don't recall that
being a sentiment
Let's uh if we could scroll down to the
entry for September 2nd 2014.
um
well I'd like to direct your attention
to a sentence in the middle of this
entry it says RN and CT discuss
CT's history and current relationship
CT records difficulty with jealousy
issues and anxiety around fiance's Fame
and ability to interact with females
often
um did I read that correctly
and that's a note that you wrote correct
foreign
do you recall Miss heard
um expressing the sentiment to you and
like we discussed earlier I don't recall
that specifically I do have a general
sense of
jealousy anxiety issues popping up
throughout the years
but I don't remember that that specific
um
discussion to give you anything deeper
than that
um let's first move on to the entry for
September 4th 2014.
um now I'd like to direct your attention
to this is also in the middle
um it says CT ate dinner with RN at 2100
at restaurant go ahead I'm sorry okay
um since he became frustrated with
weight stock over miscommunication CT
commonly repeated herself to staff to
resolve the issue CT expressed
frustration over conflict to rn rn
reflective change in coping mechanisms
as CT's previous coping skills involved
impulsive anger and yelling did I read
that correctly
yes
um do you recall this incident at all
I wouldn't have said that I remembered
this in preparation for the deposition
when I was rereading through these notes
I have sort of a vague memory of this
but I think my my notes here probably
are more specific than what I exactly
remember
um let's actually go to the entry for
September 21st 2014 and I
yes okay
um please take a moment and review this
and um once you're done
um the question is is it does this note
um reflect that that incident in in
London that you just referred to
answer your question
yes that is what I'm referring to
foreign
it says down here at the bottom of the
notes uh client's fiance offered a
promotional support
um that accurate your our collection
you don't recall or we'd have to refer
to my nursing note as
it's probably a lot more reliable than
my current memory
um I believe you testified earlier
though that you recall that Mr deck was
present um on this occasion is that
right
now we've moved on to the entry for
September 22nd
okay so this note begins
um
is this this it's like that
um this starts with
0100 is that one o'clock in the morning
on September 22nd
but ARA notified that client requires
assistance upon arrival client noted to
appear irritable loud and angry fine
screaming at times and appears agitated
um
clients crying and say she got into a
verbal argument with fiance after RN
departure
does this reflect refresh your
recollection at all about
um
it's heard having a
an outburst I don't know that it
refreshes my memory I would say it
reflects my memory
is this this is the same Outburst in
London that you have been previously
referring to
that's correct
um
do you recall anything about what the
fight between Mr Depp and Miss herb was
about that's reflected in this note
I don't really recall I
I remember a general
sense of misheard being very upset that
her phone was hacked because there was
very sense
of information that was leaked from it
and I feel like there was a he was
having a difficult time
calming after that
so
what there was any verbal disagreements
I would assume it's in relation to that
but I I just don't remember the
specifics of
what that disagreement was about
it says here uh a fine State she feels
Beyonce did not provide support on it
did I read that right
okay
is that consistent with your
recollection
I didn't recall that but again I would
state that
my notes are much more reliable than my
current memory and I think that probably
speaks to your previous question
um well let's please
um go to the entries which for March 7th
2015 which are on page
uh with the base number one six nine
five two
three earlier
um do you recall that
yes
um now with respect to the entry for
March 7 2015.
um
it says uh client notifies RN via text
of increasing anxiety reports emotional
ability
um
protein
do you recall with her reporting why she
was feeling anxious at this time
no I don't recall the specific reason of
why she is
notifying me of that at this time
is this so it says here that to notify
you via text right right
and directing your attention to the next
note from March 8th 2015
um and I know you discussed this with
Adam earlier so I won't belabor this too
much um but
um do you recall that this
a time of this entry on March 8th 2015
Miss heard was in Australia
we would make that assumption based upon
my note for March 8th
um a state that client will be returning
to Los Angeles accompanied by house
manager Ben I'm paraphrasing there but
uh yes I I believe she was coming from
Australia for this particular entry
it says here are in plans to meet client
upon arrival
you see that
that oh yes yes I do
um and
surprised you this earlier you did see
misheard the next day when she arrived
back in last in Los Angeles is that
correct
correct if you look at the entry for
March 9th I refer to meeting her
and her friends so yes I would have met
her in person at the
um do you recall how long you spent with
Miss hurt that following day
I don't recall my notes states that I
met her for dinner at 2200 which
military time would be 10 P.M
I don't recall how long I was with her
so I would assume a couple hours but
again that I'm just making an assumption
um
do you recall observing any injuries to
miss her when she when you saw her on
March 9 2015. no I don't recall I don't
I don't make
note of it but I don't recall either
um is is Miss hurt had visible injuries
is that something that you would have
documented in your nursing notes
I would assume so you uh recall Miss
heard seeking any medical treatment from
you when you saw her on March 9th 2015.
don't recall
um
if this hurt has sought medical
treatment from you on that date is that
something you would have documented in
your notes
perhaps if there were requests from
medical treatment
that differed from sort of day-to-day
status then yes I might have put it in
my notes if I hadn't discussed with Dr
Kipper but I
I don't make any
um reference to it in this particular
note
could we please pull up
um what should be
in
in I think I would have uploaded this
document B
uh it Affairs the base members Pilates
zero one three four
teams
um
I think we covered this before but just
to confirm um
is this your email up at the top that
says erinborne hotmail.com
I'm sorry if you respond
oh great thank you I'm sorry I didn't
hear that um okay I'd like to direct
your attention down to this email from
David Kipper on March 9 2015.
um that's our parents would be too much
do you recognize the scene
please
I believe I produced this in
um reference to the subpoena
do you recall receiving this email
they don't recall but I do remember
ing this I don't think I reviewed it in
preparation for today but probably at
the time of
the document request I think I probably
reviewed this
um
directing your attention to the middle
of the email do you see where it says
um
I'm sure JD will let her know we are
coming home I want her to please not see
him for a few days until we can get him
organized with a hand surgeon and get
his meds balance
do you see that
and JD refers to Mr death in this
instance
yes and the her is misheard
yes
um did you have an understanding of the
time as to why Dr Kipper didn't want
miss her to see Mr Depp for a few days
I don't recall exactly this
might have been in reference
to Australia when they
meeting Mr Depp and misheard were
separated
I would have to check the dates on that
um
I well turning back to your notes where
Miss herb was returning from March from
Australia March 9 2015 is that Orient
you know who yes yes thank you yeah that
would be the same time period okay
um
and you alluded to an understanding that
Dr Kipper wanted Mr Deb and Miss herb
separated
yes
and
why why didn't you what was your
understanding as to why they should be
suffering
we don't recall specifics
um it wasn't present in Australia at
that time
I just remember
a general sense of
a big argument happening and the
treatment team deciding that they should
not be around each other so Ms heard
returned to Los Angeles
and Mr duck stayed in Australia for how
long I I don't recall
the next thing here says please use
these excuse that Dr Kipper insists that
Jay you stay quiet without any
distraction for the rest of the week
while we get his medication organized
balance none of this will be accepted by
her but I will be very upset you can
tell her this if there is any stress
created by a visit that's premature do
you see that yes
um
do you have any understanding as to why
Dr Kipper was
directing you to provide this excuse to
miss heard yeah and just the general
sense that there was a major argument in
Australia which I wasn't present for and
separating because
um because of that
did you have any understanding as to why
Dr Kipper stated that none of this will
be accepted by misheard
I would be speculating on that but you
know we we used joking terminology
expert at this time in March of 2015.
um
would you agree or did you agree with Dr
Kipper that misheard would not
um accept
not seeing Mr Depp for a period of time
I don't know specifically I
as I think we talked about much earlier
this morning
there was generally a sense of arguing
reconciling in that sort of cycle
happening frequently throughout their
relationship
if we could please go back to the
nursing nodes which are um exhibit too
um and could we please go back to the
um entries from March 2015 that are on
the page with the page number 169502.
um now we covered this earlier but um it
says in in your March 9 2015 entry it
says client states you would like to
discuss recent events between her and
husband with RNN private tomorrow do you
see that
so yes I do
directing your attention to the entry
for March 10th 2015.
um it says RN
Amendment 1600. does that
um refresh your recollection that you
did meet with her the next day
no it doesn't refresh my recollection
however I would refer to my nurse
account do you have any reason to doubt
that these notes are accurate
no
do you recall what they're misheard
showed any injuries to you on that at
that time
oh I don't recall any
injuries
injuries okay
um can we go back to exhibiting two
which is the nursing notes and
specifically
um the entry for
um March 25th 2015. let's go back up to
the the top of this entry for March
2015.
um
and I just want to ask you about one
more part of this it says states she is
concerned about ability to trust fiance
following argument on March 23 2015.
um
do you have any recollection of Miss
heard expressing
um
concern about her ability to trust Mr
Depp I would say I have a
generalized memory of their being as I
stated before jealousy and anxiety
issues
um including mistrust within the
relationship
do you recall Miss heard ever telling
you that she thought Mr Duff was
cheating on her
no I don't recall that specifically I
just
as I said have a general sense of
uh remembering jealousy being an issue
if we could
um
okay I think uh do you recall talking
about
for Thanksgiving
um earlier today
does anything stand out on your mind as
um from that Thanksgiving dinner that
you can recall
nothing really stands out other than it
was
I I sort of have a general sense of it
being a really jovial
fun time together
do you recall how long you you stayed at
the dinner
specifically I would assume
a few hours
um could we please just quickly go to
the note from November this is an
exhibit two
um and then and three for November 26
2015 which is on page
um 16954.
December
um
municipalotti directing her attention to
the entry for November 26 2015.
um would you uh looked at the knew you
were calling this entry earlier today
and I believe you testify that this is
the entry from the Thanksgiving dinner
that you spend with Miss heard and Mr
Duff
I believe it is
um do you see in the Middle where it
says um Davey appeared calm and coherent
I do
um
is that accurate to your recollection of
that evening
again I don't remember that specifically
but I just remember a general sense of
it being a
of fun happy
evening
so this is
consistent with your recollection of
that evening
I would make that assumption
and
you have no reason to doubt the accuracy
of your your note
directing your attention to the December
17th 2015 entry
um
will you just take a minute and read
this over and confirm whether
strike that
um do you recall going and visiting Miss
heard on December 15th excuse me
December 17 2015.
and remember in so much as
my nursing notes regarding this
night I I don't say I can't say that I
recall much more than I have here but I
I do remember visiting her
um
it says here that the client had visible
bright red blood appearing at Center of
lower lip
do you see that
yes
did you
um
other than the blood on this heart's leg
do you recall seeing any other injuries
to her on that date
or call other than
what I stayed
new exam do you recall examining this
hurts lipit phone
I don't think I examined it other than a
visual
um
examination I I didn't physically
examine
for what
the note says here a client also stated
her head is bruised and that she lost
clumps of hair and altercation RN
briefly looked at client's scalp but was
unable to visualize hematoma's client
had described is that what you wrote in
your note
um if you had observed the the bruises
or hematomas that misheard had described
would that have been reflected in your
nose
would assume but again I'm I'm not
trained in looking for those types of
injuries which is why my note continues
that I encourage her to be seen by a
professional that is trained to do so
um before we drop down to the next page
and this is just the end of portion of
this note
um
it's those here
um
I'm reminds client to hydrate with oral
fluids and to limit abstain from alcohol
client was consuming red wine when with
RN
left but assured RNG would consume in
moderation
is that what you wrote in your note
it is and I I believe I uh
Miss wrote there probably it should say
client was consuming red wine when R and
left not with
just to clarify
why would you advise Miss heard on this
occasion to limit or why did you
advise Miss heard to limit or abstain
from alcohol in this occasion I don't
recall why I would be speaking to the
Limit or abstain from alcohol
to confirm
based on your nursing notes you were
aware that misheard claimed to have been
injured by Mr death in December of 2015
correct and you went and actually saw
her
shortly after that alleged incident
correct
not that same day but
possibly the the following day I believe
and
you look on that occasion he observed
that she did she had a bloody lip
correct
correct and she told you that that was a
result of
um the altercation with Mr Duck Right
right
if she had had any other injuries on
that occasion can would you have
recorded them in your nursing homes
make that assumption based upon my other
notes that reference
the blood on her lip
and could we go back to the exhibit two
and the nursing notes for April 21st
2016.
what's
pictures on
age number 16957
where it says aren't socialize with JD
for 45 minutes JD appeared coherent
oriented and sociable
thought process logical and clear
do you have any reason to doubt that
that's accurate that's an accurate
description of Mr death on that date
Jessica I apologize can you just use
your cursor to help me see the note that
you were just reading
or it's it's
um
sorry I actually don't have control of
it but it um it's down it's down towards
the middle it says RN socialize with
safety at
times 45 minutes
JD appeared coherent oriented and social
probably yes I'm I I see it thank you
logical and clear yeah okay
okay oh I'm sorry what was your question
regarding that
um
do you have any reason to doubt that
that was an accurate description of how
Mr death appeared to you on
April 21st 2016. I have no reason to
doubt it I would stand by my notes
um
you knew that Mr Depp was being treated
for um
substance abuse issues
um by Dr Kipper and
nurse Deputy Lloyd French
yes
um if if Mr Depp had appeared
intoxicated on this occasion is that
something that he would have documented
because it had been outwardly visible
for either clients I wouldn't have made
reference to that
we could go back to the nursing notes
it's hit it too please
and um if we could go down to the entry
for May 11th
um
you know
um this body we looked at this you
looked at this
um entry earlier today perhaps
directing your attention to just a
couple lines down it says
client discussed her birthday trip to
Coachella Music Festival trip was April
22nd 2016 through April 24th 2016.
client admits to illicit drug use during
the trip and stage she ingested
mushrooms and mg
obviously while also consuming alcohol
and state she vomited and was quote high
for at least 24 hours straight end quote
you see that
yes there you see that did I read that
correctly
yes you did and do you recall
um well first of all
um do you recall miss her relaying this
to you
I don't recall these specifics that I
State here in the note but I remember
sort of a conversation talking about
a trip after they had returned
and this starts out client admits to
illicit drug use so
am I correct that this is based on these
notes this is something Miss heard
reported to you directly again I don't
remember these specifics however my
usage of
client admits
refers to a client reporting something
to me
apparently
had Miss heard ever admitted to illicit
drug use to you before this time
I believe in reference to my nursing
notes from when I
first
met her uh he alluded to previous
substance use
it says here RN remind declined that a
list of drug use will not be tolerated
by medical staff
and that any medications or drugs that
are not prescribed can interfere and
cause adverse effects with with her
prescribed medication
client laughed and also reported using a
list of drugs mushrooms and MDMA on May
9 2016 a home with a high profile nail
appointments did I read that correctly
yes you did
um
do you recall Miss hurt laughing in
response to your
reminder about illicit drug use no I
don't recall that
in your
time carrying firm is heard did you ever
see Mr dot physically abused
did you ever see misheard physically
abused Mr death
did you ever see Miss heard throw
anything at Mr death
that you cared for her
I did not witness that
in
um
in the time that you treated her
did you ever see Miss heard lose her
temper
as we talked previously
the one incident that I can remember is
in London
2014.
yes 2014.
um in regards to
the phone being hacked and sensitive
material being leaked
foreign
did you ever feel that misheard was
um hostile towards you at any time
during your treatment of her
did you ever feel like she was ignoring
um attempts by you to contact her yes I
have a general memory of
ten not often I should not speaking
of that happening on more than one
occasion where I would reach out and not
get a response I just ever remember
feeling frustrated by that
when had you treated domestic
prior to this time
the time that I worked with them was in
nursing school
um
I don't want to say the specific place
for confidentiality reasons
but it was for domestic plans
um
sort of a safe safe house yes do you
remember
when you were treating misheard that at
some point she had a cyst on her eyelid
yes that sounds familiar and do you
remember that
um he had a procedure to have
cyst removed
yes
and was that a surgical procedure to
reflection
from what I recall that was
handled at
an Outpatient Surgical Center
other than that I don't know the details
of that
do you recall whether Miss heard had any
marks around her eye after having that
procedure
I don't recall I remember
a topical ointment being applied but I
don't recall if there were marks on her
eye
at this point the questioning switches
back to council for misheard all right
thank you
93 okay
and and
this is a this is another picture of of
Amber from May 21st 2016. correct this
is a picture of
misheard
Amber sent you this text on May 21st
2016.
I believe so based on the time stamp
and the same for this picture on the
next page Amber sent you this picture of
her
oh correct
and the same for this page the next page
Amber sent you this picture of her on
May 21st
when you um
don't when you saw
um
Amber on December 17 2015 and you know
you spoke about that how how long did
how long were you with her do you recall
not recall I
would assume based on the fact that I
stopped by briefly
maybe an hour or two okay did you go
inside her house or were you outside the
door
from what I recall I was inside
okay
by the way when you saw Amber on
December 17th
um was she wearing makeup or would not
you recall
yeah
I don't recall
all right thank you before we get to the
next witness could I have Council
approach on the plaintiffs 46
.
all right so planus 46 is an Evidence
your next Witness
yes
plenty of calls Michael Spindler all
right Mr Spindler
yes
you know
here
do you selling Square orbital testify
truthfully in this case in the penalty
of law I do
good morning sir good morning would you
state your name for the record Michael
Spindler
what where do you live
I live in Los Angeles California area
what's your occupy occupation
I'm a forensic accountant
what do you mean by forensic accounting
well forensic accountant does accounting
work that is a bit more investigative in
nature
so it's essentially taking a look at
business records and accounting records
in connection with some form of business
issue
how long have you worked in that field
I've been a forensic accountant
full-time since 1990. what'd you do
before that before that I spent about 10
years doing auditing of financial
statements
can you describe your educational
background
yes I graduated in 1981 from the State
University of New York at Albany with a
Bachelor of Science degree in accounting
and a minor in economics
are you currently employed I am who's
your employer B Riley advisory services
what's B Riley advisory Services it's a
national forensic accounting Boutique
firm that does forensic accounting
business valuations and appraisals and
bankruptcy and restructuring work
how long have you been employed at B
Riley since January of 2015
what did you do for work prior to B
Riley
well it's a long career so I'll give you
the highlights I spent about 30 years
with national accounting firms as
partner at two different firms
and also was involved with a couple of
forensic accounting Boutique firms
okay
do you hold any certifications I do
what are they
I'm a certified public accountant with
licenses from Six States New York
California Arizona Nevada Utah and
Hawaii
I'm also certified in financial
forensics I'm a certified fraud Examiner
I'm accredited in business valuation and
a certified anti-money laundering
specialist
participate in any professional
organizations I do what are those
well I've had leadership positions and a
couple of them I'll mention the
association of certified fraud examiners
I was the president of the Los Angeles
chapter and I'm currently on their board
I've been actively involved with the
California Society of CPAs
I was a president of the Los Angeles
chapter it had 11 000 members at the
time
was also on Cal CPA Council which is
kind of their board of directors and
also a member of the Board of Trustees
of the Cal CPA Education Foundation
have you testified as an expert before I
have
approximately how many times uh about a
hundred times roughly uh about half of
that in uh trials and arbitrations
what's your typical role in those cases
typically it can take a number of forms
but commonly I will testify with respect
to damages
have you done any film industry work yes
I have what was that I've done work
involving all the major film studios
I've also done work on behalf of writers
directors producers Actors Studio
executives
your honor I'd like to proffer Mr
Spindler as an expert in forensic
accounting all right any objection
all right so move thank you
what work did you do in this case
well in this case I was asked to take a
look at issues with respect to Lost
earnings for Mr Depp
what imp
Lor uh did you do
I looked at accounting records that were
produced by Mr Depp's accounting firm Ed
White and Company
I looked at trial exhibits I looked at
deposition testimony I looked at some
trial testimony and I've looked at
various other documents and Exhibits in
connection with the case
what specific period did you analyze
with respect to Lost earnings
I looked at the period following the
publication of the op-ed so I looked at
the period from
December 18th 2018 through October 31st
2020.
I looked at the accounting records that
have been produced by Mr Depp's
accountants
uh any other materials
various
deposition transcripts trial testimony
contracts Etc
what conclusions did you draw from your
review
I concluded that Mr Depp suffered lost
earnings of approximately 40 million
dollars
how did you reach that conclusion
well there are really two main
components to that
the first relates to the loss of the
role of Captain Jack Sparrow and the
pirate 6 film
so the loss relate to the loss of that
role in that franchise picture
it was 22.5 million dollars based on
testimony provided by Mr Jack Wiggum
in addition we looked at yes
did you do anything
uh well we also calculated the net
earnings that Mr debb would have
received from that
okay
um
and what did you base your analysis of
pirate 6 on
based on the testimony of Mr Jack
Wickham okay what else did you do with
respect to uh the Lost earning analysis
that you did
well the other main component to this is
taking a look at
all the other roles the non-franchise
films
so those
films Studio films Independent films and
endorsements that Mr Depp realizes and
and enjoys
so in connection with that we looked at
his bookings for the year 2017.
and by bookings I mean
instances where Mr Depp is hired for a
project
and
he receives that first money related to
that project in 2017. so in other words
you've got a deal
and cash showed up so it's real
so he looked at his 2017 bookings
and we calculated for that year for that
period his bookings were about 17.5
million dollars
the main components of that Mr Wiggum
testified to
we then looked at
the period of time following the op-ed
of December 18 2018 through October 31st
2020.
so if annual earnings was 17.5 million
dollars
in what is
known as a typical year a reasonable
base year
at that rate what would we have expected
Mr Depp to have earned
from that period of October 18 2018
through October 31st 2020.
and we then compared that to his
bookings his actual bookings for that
period of time
2017 as a as a typical base year
well a couple of reasons first of all Mr
Wiggum testified that that was a typical
year
for Mr Depp
and it's also the most recent clean year
that was experienced in 2018 yet the
publication of the op-ed that didn't
happen in 2017.
okay
did you do anything did you prepare
anything to assist the jury with respect
to the analysis that you perform we did
prepare a chart yes
Joanna may approach all right yes sir
thank you
you're I think this is plaintiff exhibit
12 40. I'm going to uh I'm not going to
move it into evidence I'm simply just
going to use it
with your permission to publish it to
the jury so that the witness can explain
it or any objection to demonstrative
all right well um do you have electronic
copy of it okay that's fine
who did this chart
uh I in combination with people working
under my direction from my firm all
right
can you explain to the jury what uh
you've done here
sure I'd be happy to uh so as we
discussed previously
uh Mr Depp lost the role in Pirate six
and the effect of that was lost earnings
of 22.5 million dollars based on Mr
wiggum's testimony
and then what we've shown here is the 10
agent commission
because that's the rate for uh Mr uh
Depp's agent that's what his agent
receives out of Mr Depp's earnings in
connection with setting up a project for
Mr Depp so we deduct that 10 which comes
to 250 000 just ten percent of 22.5
million
and the net effect of that the amount
that Mr Dev would have received after
deducting that fee would have been 20
billion two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
and that's the first component of this
what did you do in terms of the analysis
of
of lost bookings for non-franchise films
okay so that's the next section of the
chart and as I mentioned before his 2017
bookings were about 17.5 million dollars
so that rate of earnings
over the period from mid-December
through the end of October 2020 or
mid-December 2018 through the end of
October 2020.
would come to about 32.8 32.9 million
dollars
that we then compared that to actual
bookings during that period of time of
mid-December 2018 through the end of
October 2020. that amount was 10 million
586 thousand dollars
we deducted those bookings the actual
amounts from what we would have expected
to arrive at his lost bookings for
non-franchise activity and that comes to
about 22.3 million dollars and once
again we've deducted the 10 ages
Commission
uh so the net effect
that lost earnings to Mr Depp after that
agent's fee for
non-pirate films comes to about 20
million dollars what does the figure at
the bottom corner of the chart the 40
million 318
dollars and uh
40 million three eighteen two thirty
seven what does that represent well
that's your grand total that's the sum
of those two components for total lost
earnings
uh 40.3 million dollars
no further questions sure all right
cross-examination
thank you your honor good morning Mr
Spindler good morning
foreign
so this this lawsuit isn't the first
time you've worked with Johnny Depp is
it
it is not you've worked with him in a
lawsuit uh that he had in the past with
his old Law Firm correct yeah it's just
a little bit of work yes and
um so in this second go-round is as a
paid expert for Mr Depp you're you're
making uh 550 an hour is what he's
paying you is that right that's the
amount that my firm bills I do not
receive that
now the subject matter of your opinion
testimony in this case is the economic
damages that Mr Depp has allegedly
suffered as a result of misheard's
December 8 2018 op-ed correct
correct yes and this is the first case
in which you've testified as an expert
relating to economic damages claimed by
an actor correct
first time I've testified to but I've
done that work before
and you understand that this case is
about only whether Miss herds December
18 2018 op-ed constitutes defamation of
Mr Depp correct
that's my understanding and you
understand that this case isn't about
anything else misheard has ever said or
done correct
I believe that's correct and to be to be
clear you were testifying only as to
allege damages right
correct so you are not offering any
opinion or any testimony on whether
those specific damages that you just
discussed were caused by the op-ed
correct that's correct and you're
assuming for the purposes of your report
that the damages that you're testifying
about were caused by Amber's op-ed
correct yes
so you're therefore not looking into
whether
anything else that's happened with Mr
Depp's life or career could have caused
him economic damages correct
I believe that's generally correct yes
so you're not looking at whether the
article published in the UK in June 2018
calling Mr Depp a wife beater caused him
the damages correct
correct you're not looking at whether
the lawsuit that he brought in the UK
against the publisher of that article
caused him those damages right
correct you're not looking at any of the
evidence that came out in that lawsuit
about alleged instances of abuse against
Amber correct
correct
you're not looking at whether the
consequences of Mr Depp's drug and
alcohol use have caused in the damages
you're discussing correct
correct you're not looking at whether
the worsening performance at the box
office of Mr def's movies over time has
caused them the damages that you're
testifying about correct
correct and I'm not acknowledging any of
this being accurate I'm just saying that
that wasn't part of my calculations sure
I understand I just want to want to make
clear what you didn't look at what
you're not opining on and so to round
that out you're not considering even the
impact of Amber obtaining a restraining
order in May 2016 and whether that may
have caused some damages that's not part
of your opinion correct well since we
were taking a look at lost bookings
using 2017 as a base year
any activity that preceded that would
have been baked into those calculations
that way and we'll get to those
calculations in a minute because I I'd
like to I'm going to put up the chart
that you put in your expert report
um but but first I want to talk about
pirate six because that's basically the
two components of your damages is pirate
six and then this
non-franchise lost bookings right
correct okay so for pirate 6
specifically you assume that he would
have made 22 and a half million dollars
on pirate six right
correct and you took Jack wiggum's word
for it in making that assumption correct
I based it on his testimony yes now you
never saw a contract that Mr Depp had
for pirate six correct correct because
no contract exists to your knowledge
correct so far as I know I've not seen
one and you didn't take into
consideration Jack Williams testimony
that Disney was non-committal about Mr
Depp being in Pirate six even before the
op-ed correct correct and you didn't
take into consideration the Press
articles that came out prior to the
op-ed that suggested that Disney had
made a decision not to cast Mr Depp in
Pirate six correct
correct
and you have no idea whether pirate 6
will ever be made
right
I wouldn't know that and you have no
idea if Disney has decided one way or
the other whether Mr Depp would be in it
or whether they'd offer him a role in it
if it is ever made correct
well my understanding is that they made
a public statement that he would not
okay
and you have
um
if Disney decided that he wouldn't be in
it you have no idea when they decided
that correct
I know that there was a public
announcement subsequent to the
publication of the op-ed what what
Public Announcement are you talking
about
I believe there was an interview of Mr
Bailey
um that was published uh several days
after oh okay well that that interview
of Mr Bailey didn't didn't say that he
wasn't going to be in it in fact have
you looked at the the article that the
jury saw the headline for yesterday
dated November 5th 2020 about Mr death
potentially not being in Pirate six have
you looked at that article I assume not
no okay and you didn't take into account
Mr Depp's statement that he wouldn't do
pirate six for 300 million dollars in a
million out Pockets correct
uh that sounded like hyperbole to me I
didn't take that very seriously okay
sound like somebody who was a bit hurt
or in pain so as a result of the loss of
the role so if Mr death didn't lose a
role in Pirate six because of the op-ed
but he lost it for other reasons then
your damages opinion relating to Pirate
six would drop to zero dollars correct
I believe that's correct if it's not
lost for that reason if it's lost for
some other independent reason then I
think that would need to be considered
okay thank you now let's shift gears and
talk about the non-franchise earnings
for a moment
um you claim this number is about 21
million dollars right
roughly
20. we could we'll we'll pull it up
um well actually we'll
look at the chart here 20 20 million
dollars about 20 million dollars after
agent fees correct okay
um and to reach that number you looked
at what his historical earnings records
showed right correct
and you got that information from Ed
White's office
yes and you assume that the information
you got from Ed White's office was
accurate right I did yes can we please
pull up um
the chart that's in this expert report
uh your honor this is
um
or Mr Spindler I'd like you to take a
look at this and confirm for the court
that this is the chart that's in your
expert report
if you would
it appears to be yes your honor I'd ask
for permission to publish this just as a
demonstrative no objection all right
so Mr Spindler
um this chart shows Mr Depp's earnings
by year based on the information that
you received from Ed White correct
correct from 2009 to 2020 yes and it
shows that from about 2009 to 2019 and I
I didn't add these up visually but from
your report you say that Mr debt made
about 459 million dollars
correct correct okay
now
the two highest earning years in this
time period were 2010 and 2011 right yes
you see that you made about 70 million
dollars in 2010
I do yes and then the third highest year
was 2014 right yeah under 60 million
and you'd agree that from the period of
2010 to 2020 his annual income on
average was decreasing
yes but you have to take a look at the
components of this right
that I was just just wanted to get your
your agreement that from 2010 to 2020
his annual income was decreasing
now
in 2020
he earned more than he did in 2016.
correct
on an overall basis yes and in 2020 he
earned more than he did in 2018. correct
yes just based on earnings and in 2018
and 2019 he earned an almost identical
amount correct
yes in 2019 and 2020 were both after the
publication date of the op-ed correct
yes okay now I want to talk about some
of these non-franchise earnings because
when I looked at your chart that was
displayed to the jury I didn't see
anything specific listed so can you just
confirm for me that you can't name a
single loss business opportunity other
than pirate six that Mr Depp lost as a
result of the op-ed
that's correct that's not the nature of
this calculation single television just
if you could just just answer my
questions yes or no as best you can
please you can't identify a single
television project that Mr Depp
allegedly lost out on as a result of the
op-ed correct correct that's not the
nature you can't identify a single
advertising campaign or marketing
opportunity that Mr Depp lost out on as
a result of the op-ed correct right
these are the calls so it's fair to say
that for the sit for for for the Lost
opportunities that you can't name you're
assuming
as with pirate six that those
opportunities were lost because of the
op-ed correct
correct now you you mentioned something
interesting um in your direct and in
your report you say that you use 2017 as
the base year to calculate
what you claim Mr Depp's
should have earned in 2019 and 20.
correct correct and let's take a look at
this because
2017 he made that much correct about 45
million or so
yes but in 2016 he made
just a shade over 20 correct
correct 2018 he made a shade under 20
right
yes same with 2019 right
correct and then 2020 he actually made
more than he had in the prior two years
or in 2016 and made about what 22 23
million or so is that right
right but as I indicated this is just
based on earnings you need to get behind
right so you said there are a couple
interesting things you said
that the most recent that 2017
um I want to explore why you relied on
that now first of all you you said that
you relied on Jack wiggum's testimony
that 2017 was a reasonable year to use
correct correct despite the fact that
2017 he made more than twice as much as
he's made in any year over the last five
years correct
yes but when you take a look at there if
I can no no no that's my question well I
wanna I wanna get to your thoughts
because you said that one of the reasons
you use 2017 was because it was you you
said I wrote down the most recent clean
year right correct and and and and then
I think you explained you said because
the op-ed was was written in 2018 right
correct but the op-ed wasn't written
until December 18th 2018. correct yes so
the first if 2017 was clean then the
first
352 days of 2018 were also clean weren't
they sir
if I may explain
Mr Wiggum testified that for the first
half of 2018
Mr Depp chose to take some vacation time
uh also he chose to go touring in the
summer with his band
and then he did a film towards the end
of 2018.
with the publication of the op-ed in
December of 2018
that would have impacted the prospects
for that film that was done in 2018 so
he chose to do just the one film in
2018.
and then the impact of the op-ed on that
film would have meant that it was not a
clean period you could not have looked
at that film to get a good sense of what
his earnings should have been because he
didn't have the chance to earn
box office bonuses whatever
participations well let's go that's why
2017 is a much much better year to use
than 2018.
I think you you let's break that down a
little bit you said that that 2017 was a
much cleaner year but isn't it also true
that there were other reasons why 2018
wasn't clean for example the June or the
the April 2018 article by Dan Wooten
calling Mr Deborah wife beater correct
that did occur that year yes the June
2018 lawsuit that Mr Depp filed in the
UK against the Sun for calling him a
wife beater correct
yes and how about the the October
articles reporting that Disney had
decided to move on from Mr death and not
cast him in Pirate six correct
I'm sorry what effect would that have
had well it became before the op-ed so
it's another reason why 2018 isn't a
clean year in your mind correct
two months before the op-ed
that would also keep 2018 from being
what you would call a clean year correct
I've described the reasons why I believe
2018 was not a clean year okay now
you're aware as we talked about that
Amber's op-ed wasn't published until
December 18 2018 correct correct so Mr
Depp could not have lost out on any
opportunities as a result of the op-ed
prior to December 18 2018. correct
correct and he couldn't have lost out on
any opportunities
uh in 2017 as a result of the op-ed fair
fair and he couldn't have lost out on
any opportunities in 2016 as a result of
the op-ed correct correct
and so in in in calculating your damages
you didn't you didn't use 2016
you didn't use 2018 but you chose to use
2017 correct
in 2020 than he did in both 28 16 and
2018 before the op-ed was published
correct
correct and that's just based on
earnings
redirect
2018. why didn't she use 2016.
well first of all 2017 was a more recent
year
2017 was a year in which Mr Wiggum
indicated that that was a typical year
for Mr Depp he had a studio film he had
a independent film he had an endorsement
deal uh 2016 is further back in time as
I understand it is earnest capacity for
that year would have been just about the
same or even higher than 2017 because
there was an endorsement deal that Mr
Depp passed on that would have been
worth a lot of money according to Ms
Jacobs so 2017 made the most sense
uh why did you ultimately use the method
that you uh did to determine the Lost
earnings
because it just makes sense it's um the
correct approach to take you're taking a
look at what Mr Depp would have been
expected to earn in a typical year
and then you're comparing that to the
period of time where you're analyzing
following the op-ed
from December of 2018 through October
2020. so you're taking a look at what
you would have expected him to earn it's
very simple compared to what he actually
did earn no further questions all right
thank you is this witness subject to
recall
all right sir since you're subject to
recall do not discuss your testimony
with anybody but since you are giving
expert testimony you're free to stay
into the courtroom okay sir thank you
have a good day thank you very much all
right watch here watch your step there
all right
uh plaintiff Restless cases all right
plane of rest all right ladies and
gentlemen we're going to go ahead and
take our morning recess it may be a
little longer because I have a few
issues to take up with the attorneys but
then uh we'll proceed after that okay so
please do not talk about the case and do
not do any outside research okay thank
you
you don't think
all right
why don't we go ahead and take our
recess till 11 45 then I'll come back
and entertain the emotions at that time
okay all right thanks
foreign
foreign
thank you
but at the same time granting a motion
to strike is appropriate when the
plaintiff as as is the case here has
failed to present evidence sufficient to
create an issue of fact on his claims
um and in addition the court may not
draw inferences from the evidence that
defy logic and common sense that's the
Austin versus shony's case 254 Virginia
134.
so the issue here your honor is a couple
fold and I'll take the statements
um well two of them in one category and
one of them in the other category but I
think we're all clear that the sole
issue here is whether Amber Heard can be
held liable to Mr Depp for defamation
arising from the 2018 op-ed and the 2018
op-ed alone
um and to establish that Mr Depp has to
prove the following elements he has to
prove that the uh the publication of the
op-ed and that it was written by
misheard he has to prove that the
statements in the op-ed were both false
and defamatory so falsity and that they
contained a sufficient defamatory sting
and he has to show that the statements
were made with the requisite intent in
this case actual malice on the part of
Amber Heard I'll save that argument till
the end your honor and I'll focus on uh
the first two at this point and because
it seems like plaintiff is proceeding
under a theory of defamation by
implication under the Pendleton case 290
Virginia 162
plaintiff Bears the burden of proving
the statements at issue were designed
and intended by misheard to imply a
defamatory meeting designed and intended
to imply defamatory meaning so and to
satisfy those first two elements
publication and falsity and defamation
or defamatory nature of the statements
Mr Depp Bears the burden of proving that
by a preponderance of the evidence and
to satisfy the requisite intent and show
that misheard acted with actual malice
he has a heightened standard of proof
that he must prove by clear and
convincing evidence that misheard acted
with that malice so just want to talk
about the two the the the two statements
on domestic abuse
in the op-ed
um and your honor is well aware of the
ample Virginia case laws talking about
how you have to view the op-ed as a
whole you have to view words in context
so these are the the statements that
that read then two years ago I became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and then the other statement that
says I had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse now those
statements are entirely opinion except
for according to Mr Depp the discussion
of domestic abuse so the statement I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and the statement in the
second sentence that Mr Depp was a man
accused of abuse the rest of those are
inactionable opinion
statements now the evidence educed thus
far your honor shows that Mr Depp can't
sustain a claim on these for two reasons
first of all the statements are true on
their face I don't think that there's
any dispute about that and that's been
the subject of of some testimony in this
case uh two years before she wrote the
op-ed miss her did in fact become a
public figure representing domestic
abuse when she obtained a domestic
violence restraining order against Mr
Depp and the Mr Depp was indeed accused
of abuse those are facts that are true
now to the extent that Mr death will
argue that he's proceeding on a
defamation by implication claim again
um
the court should Grant the motion to
strike because the Undisputed evidence
is that he did in fact abuse Amber now
there is there's a dispute in this case
there's ample evidence that he
physically abused Amber but we
acknowledge that there's a dispute in
this case on that but what there is in
the dispute in this case is non-physical
abuse both Mr death and his expert
Shannon Curry have testified that abuse
may come in many forms it may be
physical certainly but it may also be
verbal maybe emotional maybe
psychological
you'll recall Mr Depp
um even kind of setting the Baseline for
what abuse was when he talked about the
non-physical abuse that he allegedly
suffered at the hands of his mother he
said it was worse than the beatings and
the example he gave was that his mom
used to uh used to call him one eye as
an example because he had a lazy eye I
guess as a child that was something that
Mr Depp himself said was abuse his mom
calling him one eye so he's setting
aside the evidence of physical abuse in
this case which is already overwhelming
Mr Depp's claims relating to these two
statements should be stricken because of
the ample and Undisputed evidence in the
record of non-physical abuse by Mr Depp
toward misheard there's evidence in the
record of recordings messages including
messages Written in Blood with his
finger blood and paint vile names
shouting menacing and threatening
statements
um there's the video the kitchen video
and sweet sir there's the audio of him
calling Miss heard
um like I say numerous vile names
there's the audio of him asking to her
to cut him
um and whether she wanted to be cut so
there's there's there's plenty of
evidence out of the words or out of the
mouth of the plaintiff in this case that
constitutes non-physical abuse of
misheard again under the standard set
forth by his expert and he and the
plaintiff himself those are far worse
than his mother calling him one eye when
he was a child in addition to that your
honor there's Travis mcgivern's
testimony from yesterday in which he
testified that at a minimum on the night
of March 23 2015 both parties were being
verbally abusive to each other
Mr mcgivern also testified about Mr Depp
quote rearranging her closet throwing
racks of clothing
down onto the floor and throwing at
least one rack down the stairs now in
California property damage alone can be
a basis for getting it to a temporary
restraining order under California law
so further evidence of non-physical
abuse or non-physical toward misheard
you saw the cupboards in the sweets or
kitchen video and then Dr Laura Anderson
your honor testified that she believed
that the parties engaged in mutual abuse
and that at least some of the time that
that was initiated by Mr Depp this is
all evidence we haven't gotten to put on
our case yet and to the extent this case
proceeds and that will start now but
this is all evidence that has come in
while plaintiff controls the playing
field of what evidence has come in and
he can't overcome that
in this case your honor if Mr Depp
abused misheard
physically verbally emotionally or
psychologically even one time
then she wins on those claims then she
wins it's that simple and the evidence
is overwhelming and Undisputed in the
ways that I've just described that he
did so for that reason your honor those
claims should be stricken and I'll just
cite the union of needle trades versus
Jones case this is 268 Virginia 512 that
states if the plaintiff does not
establish the falsity of the statement
by a preponderance of the evidence in
his case in Chief he has not met his
threshold burden and the trial court
should strike the evidence and Grant
summary judgment to the defendant that's
exactly what should happen here
now move on to the second issue which is
the headline containing the phrase
sexual violence that should be stricken
for a couple reasons first your honor
the evidence is established that
misheard didn't write the headline Mr
Doherty from the ACLU that that's the
only evidence that's come in in this
case thus far plaintiffs control the app
well I understand but there's also a
stipulation that misheard would not be
called into plaintiff's case because
they would then use her testimony for
part of their case in your case right
and that's that's correct your honors
yeah I agree and that's just a different
issue that I'm not arguing I'm not
arguing that the court should strike
because they haven't put misheard on to
say to testify about the headline but I
assume part of that would be that they
would
that what they I hope they I guess they
intend to get from misheard is that she
she either wrote it or republished it
yeah what happened the next day as Miss
heard posted it on her Instagram account
and said look what I published yesterday
in the Washington Post so she adopted
the title and and her name was on the
article which contained the title and Mr
ronboy the only reason I'm sorry
only because I know that was a
stipulation so it's hard for me to say
that that's all the evidence for motion
to strike if there's a stipulation that
they're still going to get more evidence
in on that particular issue I think and
I'm happy to hand the chord the
transcript of the the April 8th hearing
because one of the things that we're not
arguing today is that because they
haven't put in evidence of the I think
it was a tweet but Mr two says it was
Instagram I don't know whatever it was
that because there was a tweet adopting
the op-ed she'd published okay before in
the Washington Post okay all right so
what I'm not arguing today is that
because they haven't gotten that tweet
into evidence or had misheard say that
she she tweeted that that we're entitled
to summary judgment this one I'm not
arguing that but that's all that we
discussed on April 8th and I'm happy to
hand the transcript up your honor and we
actually never it wasn't a stipulation
it was simply an agreement that they
didn't need to call her in their case to
make that point and then and then miss
bretahof said we'd have to agree on the
language of any stipulation they haven't
proposed anything to us and haven't
gotten back to us so I think that that's
only relevant we're not basing our
requests for for for motion strike here
on misheard not having testified to
sending that tweet but you're saying for
the motion of strike the only evidence
before the court is that the Washington
Post wrote that title correct and that's
a that's that's very different from what
happened the next day there's a
that the stipulation didn't go toward
who wrote the title that was never part
of anything and it's Undisputed and
misheard will testify that she didn't
write the title well I understand that
but but I think that Undisputed your
honor I apologize
but I I think the issue is that whether
it was republication well and I'll so
that I'll get to that next but I know
but you see the problem is how do I do a
motion strike when that evidence is
well the republication isn't
so so the evidence that's before you is
that the Washington Post wrote the
headline or that misheard didn't and
that's the only evidence and that's not
going to change the Republic the Tweet
which was the only subject of the the
discussion of the pre-trial conference
where there was no stipulation it was
just an agreement that we're not going
to base a motion to strike on them not
introducing evidence of the tweet that
that was what it was I'm happy to end
the transcript up if your honor would
like to see that but that isn't
actionable because under the lekova
versus Halper case 995 F third 134
retweeting a link doesn't constitute
republication now that case it does if
you add something to it but I just don't
know the evidence very quickly it's a
Judicial admission they admitted in this
hurts answer she admitted to the Tweet
so that establishes that she adopted the
op-ed and its entirety and it was
discussed we talked about judicial
admissions one was the op-ed itself the
second and this is reflected the honor
if I could finish my argument I mean
that
so and again we can we we can look at
the transit you understand my concerns I
do understand your concern and I guess
what I'm saying is that there's there's
two levels one is there's no dispute and
there's not going to be a dispute that
she did not write the headline so then
you look at does is the tweet actionable
and and the argument here is that as a
matter of law retweeting something isn't
actionable and so okay as under the
lookova case 995 F third 134 in that
case dealt with hyperlinks and how those
aren't actionable
um but to be very clear nothing that was
discussed on April 8th nothing that was
discussed at that pre-trial conference
was in any way relating to any
stipulation about who wrote the headline
it was simply that they need not call
misheard in their case in Chief to get
her to say that she sent a certain tweet
and that tweet's not in evidence yet but
it I assume that they'll try to put it
in evidence at some point but that's you
the Tweet doesn't need to be in evidence
for you to strike this this claim on
that basis
so
um even assuming
um even assuming that the headline
implied certain conduct by Mr Depp again
Mr Depp can't meet his burden of proof
on this
third your honor he can't prove that
misheard acted with actual malice Mr
Depp hasn't introduced evidence
sufficient to permit him to meet this
now again this is a heightened burden of
proof he has to show actual malice by
clear and convincing evidence and as the
Bose Corporation case from the U.S
Supreme Court it talks about the role of
of Judges as Gatekeepers of the of the
Constitution of the First Amendment and
the role of firing entry of a judgment
that's not supported by clear and
convincing proof now that case was about
appellate review
of First Amendment issues but the same
holds true for your honor here here he
hasn't introduced Mr Depp hasn't
introduced any evidence and there can't
be a reasonable inference drawn that
would permit a jury to find by that he's
proven by clear and convincing evidence
that misheard wrote the words with
actual malice and again we go back to
the testimony of Mr Dougherty which is
was their witness they put him in and Mr
Doherty the only evidence relating to to
intent or anything relating to this
op-ed which was again maybe Mr two will
try to say that we stipulated to miss
herd's intent on April 8th which of
course we didn't but the only evidence
that has been presented in this case
your honor by Mr Doherty was that the
op-ed wasn't misheard's idea that the
ACLU asked her to write the op-ed and
and indeed that they even wrote the
first draft and then that misheard
vetted the finished article with her
lawyers and with lawyers from the ACLU
to make sure that it wasn't problematic
that is the only evidence in the record
and on that evidence there cannot be a
conclusion that misheard acted with the
actual malice that's necessary
particularly when you consider the
heightened burden of proof
um so reviewing the op-ed as a whole
with the court acting in its appropriate
function as a gatekeeper of the First
Amendment we ask that uh that the courts
strike plaintiff's evidence and award
summary judgment to misheard either in
whole or in part thank you all right
thank you yes sir
good morning your honor may please the
court bench you for playing of Johnny
Depp it's just still morning your honor
if I may approach
all right
thank you thank you
uh I've just handed to Mr rottenborn in
your honor and opposition that we
prepared before we had the benefit of
seeing
Miss heard's uh affirmative motion to
strike but I think we've anticipated uh
the arguments made such as they are
the court should deny defendant Amber
heard's motion to strike because Mr Depp
has come forward in his case in Chief
with multiple credible Witnesses
documents and authentic tape recordings
of misheard herself
not only satisfying all of the requisite
elements of his claim for defamation
including actual malice but also going
the extra mile of showing that miss her
physically abused him she's the abuser
in this courtroom
uh your honor going back to the standard
as your honor is well aware and
considering a motion to strike the trial
court must view the evidence in all
reasonable inferences drawn from the
evidence in light of the most in the
light
most favorable to the plaintiff
any reasonable doubt as to whether the
plaintiff has produced sufficient
evidence of the wrong alleged must be
resolved in the plaintiff's favor and
the motion to strike denied unquote and
that's the Boeing case I believe Mr
rottenborn referred to
243 Virginia 81 at 81 1992.
quote the weight and credibility of the
testimony of witnesses or solely matters
for the jury the jury May accept that
part of the testimony it believes and
reject that which it does not it is also
within the exclusive province of the
jury to draw any reasonable inferences
from the evidence before it citing rape
versus Minix
275 Virginia 579 at 585.
in deference and respect to the Court's
time Mr Depp incorporates by reference
the legal analysis set forth in the
Court's opinion letter dated March 27
2020
overruling Ms herds demora to the three
defamatory statements at issue and that
letter opinion is attached to this
exhibit one to Mr Depp's opposition
that's where the court fulfilled its
proper gatekeeping
uh role that Mr rottenborn referred to
as a threshold matter
the elements of a defamation claim are
the following publication
of an actionable statement with the
requisite intent citing the Shaker
versus unfault case 290 Virginia 81 at
91.
as to damages they are presumed here
because misheard's false allegations of
domestic abuse sexual assault and rape
constitute defamation per se citing the
Tron field case 272 Virginia 709 713 a
2006 case
as the court noted at page three of its
opinion letter typically an editorial or
op-ed column is ordinarily not
actionable because it appears in a place
devoted to or in a manner usually
thought of as representing personal
viewpoints
ID however Virginia recognizes that
quote a defamatory charge may be made by
inference implication or insinuation
citing the car while case
and a statement expressing a defamatory
meaning may not be apparent on its face
citing Pendleton with which the court is
quite familiar 290 Virginia at 172.
accordingly in order to render words
defamatory and actionable it is not
necessary that the defamatory charge be
in direct terms but may be made
indirectly and it matters not how Artful
or disguised the most modes in which the
meaning is concealed if it is in fact
defamatory car while 196 Virginia at 7.
and based on the authority and reasoning
set forth in Pages four through eight of
the opinion letter the three statements
at issue are actionable under a theory
of defamation by implication
Mr Depp established in his case in Chief
that Ms heard in fact made all three of
the defamatory statements at issue as
the court admitted into evidence as
plaintiff's exhibit one the op-ed
mispeard published in her own name in
The Washington Post on December 18 2018.
and let's take the three statements and
the proof that has been induced
statement number one Amber Heard quote I
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
per page six of the opinion letter the
first statement could reasonably convey
the alleged defamatory meaning I.E that
Mr Depp abused misheard to its readers
without extending the words beyond their
ordinary and common
acceptation see Pendleton 290 Virginia
at 172 also citing the car well
case resolving every Fair inference in
Mr Depp's favor this statement could
reasonably imply that the sexual
violence misheard spoke up against was
in fact perpetrated by Mr debt Mr Depp
produced several credible Witnesses and
documents proving that misheard was
implying that he committed sexual
violence against her Mr Depp himself
testified to that as did his sister
Christy Dombrowski Mr Depp's former
agent Christian Carino testified that as
did his current wit Uh current agent
Jack Wiggum but perhaps most convincing
of all and most disgusting of all was
the testimony of the aclu's Terence
Doherty a lawyer nonetheless
Mr Doherty testified
among other things
uh that when the op-ed when they were
pitching the op-ed to The Washington
Post they stated hey Michael wondering
if we might interest you in a piece by
Amber Heard who as you may recall was
beaten up during her brief marriage to
Johnny Depp on what the incoming
Congress can do to help protect women in
similar situations
uh Mr Doherty also
testified that everybody understood as
misheard in the ACLU clearly intended
that these this statement and the other
two statements referred directly to Mr
Depp quote this is an article that was
in USA Today and specifically ties
Amber's statement in her op-ed piece to
Johnny Depp
and when Jessica whites who actually
wrote the op-ed that misheard later
adopted she says quote to Mr Doherty so
much for not mentioning JD when the USA
Today made clear that they like
everybody else who read the op-ed
understood that as misheard clearly
intended it referred to Mr dapp which
makes her Instagram post two days before
the trial began
that she didn't mention Mr Depp all the
more outrageous
your honor uh there is
um
Miss Shulman also at the sgo you
acknowledged that Miss Hertz op-ed
referred to Mr Depp
so it's very clear that the ACLU and
misheard intended that that was the
whole purpose of this so that they could
get interest in this and it would
coincide
with the premiere of Aquaman because
otherwise no one would have been
interested in anything written by
misheard
Mr Doherty also testified that misheard
only paid 1.3 actually she didn't even
pay all that out of the 3.5 million
dollars that she had pledged to the ACLU
and then they helped her lie about it
and it's one thing your honor uh for her
to stiff the ACLU which frankly played a
reprehensible role in this case it's
quite another for her to fail to honor
her obligation to the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles with sick and
dying children uh and that she failed to
do as well
uh and as your honor has mentioned uh
the fact that she put her name on that
article uh means that she is responsible
for all of those statements
uh which she specifically adopted later
and I'll go through the other two
statements quickly your honor well can
we stay on this one for one moment
though yes because do you agree that the
only evidence before that we've heard in
this trial as far as the title of the
op-ed is that even Mr Doherty I believe
testified to it that it was something
that Washington Post wrote well for the
for the one online he's not our witness
your honor that's a witness from the
ACLU I understand but it's the only
evidence I have I respectfully disagree
your honor all right what the only real
evidence your honor has is plaintiff's
exhibit one which is Amber Heard putting
her name on the entire article including
the title that is the only evidence
before you the ACLU was a co-conspirator
with Ms heard and whether they say oh
maybe the Washington Post wrote it
that's not the end of the story all she
has done is create an issue of an issue
of fact as to whether she wrote the
title or not so yes you're saying just
having that exhibit in evidence is
absolutely absolutely your honor her
name is on the article what what does an
average reader expect so that alone is
sufficient to beat emotion to strike if
they want to come back later and say gee
she didn't write the title as if that
were a defense I I hope they make that
argument I hope they make that argument
to the jury because it's about as
credible as her as her argument that oh
I wasn't referring to to Johnny Depp she
didn't have to and the testimony of
parents Doherty was very clear that when
they took out the references to Johnny
Depp no one was interested in this
article anymore so she said put it back
in put it back in make it more spicy so
people would read otherwise she couldn't
get it in the Washington Post it would
be back in teenage vote which is the
other publication that was considering
publishing it because no one was
interested in what she had to say in
which in unless she was defaming Mr duck
but if I could go to the second
statement I'll try to be quicker on her
two years ago I became a public figure
representing domestic abuse and I felt
the full force of our culture's Wrath
for women who speak out
as for the second statement defendant
called herself a public figure
representing domestic abuse which can be
read to imply that she became a
representative of domestic abuse because
she was abused by Mr Depp not because
not just because she spoke out against
alleged abuse this inference can be
drawn without extending the language
Beyond its ordinary common acceptations
citing Carlisle 196 Virginia at 8.
uh your honored quote to constitute a
publication
it is not necessary that the contents of
the writing should be made made known to
the public generally it is enough it is
said if they are made known to a single
person unquote citing Snyder versus
fatherly 158 Virginia 335 at 350.
everybody and his grandmother testified
that misheard was referring to her bogus
ex party tro that she obtained on May 27
2016 and it was interesting that Mr
Depp's own lawyer said that she wasn't
even provided notice so misheard made
very sure that Mr Depp wouldn't have
notice of the ex-party tro and misheard
herself the evidence shows knew that Mr
Depp having just suffered the loss of
his mother was already on the other side
of the country it was already in New
York at the time of this tro and was
heading to Europe for several weeks so
she knew she didn't need any protection
from him this was just a scam for her to
get the seven million dollars in the
divorce settlement that she said she
gave to the ACLU she swore she gave to
the ACLU and the Children's Hospital of
Los Angeles and she pocketed instead
Mr Depp Mr Broski Mr Carino Mr Wiggum
and the inevitable Mr authority of the
ACLU which lent its once respected name
to miss herd's defamation
so while misheard may have avoided any
direct mention of Mr Depp's name there
is extensive testimony and evidence in
the record showing that the implication
of her op-ed could not be more clear I.E
that Mr Depp abused misheard during the
course of their marriage under Virginia
law quote it is not necessary that the
defamatory charge be in direct terms but
it may be made indirectly and it matters
not how Artful or disguised the modes in
which the meaning is concealed if it is
in fact defamatory citing car while we
can argue as to how Artful it was but
the implication was very clear as the
court has previously
uh ruled or not law of the case but as
the court has uh persuasively written in
its opinion letter
let's move to the falsity of Ms hurts
ever evolving and ever escalating change
of ipv and sexual assault
Mr Depp's sworn denial is all he needs
to survive a motion to strike but
there's a lot more than that your honor
and I'll try to be brief
three police officers actually four but
the three who've testified already
officer signs Hadden and Gatlin
testified unequivocally that Ms heard
did not have a mark on her on the
evening of May 21 2016.
uh and I I could go through uh I'll just
go through very quickly officer hadn't
uh strike that officer Melissa science
on jury trial day 10. question did you
provide a copy of this pamphlet to Amber
Heard answer I did not I didn't identify
her as a victim of domestic abuse the
next day officer Melissa science
okay at this time did you notice any
injuries on misheard officer science I
did not
question okay were you looking to see if
she had any injuries on her at the time
officer signs yes I was
question and so you were looking to see
if Miss heard had any injuries and you
determined that she did not is that
accurate officer science correct
question okay and was the lighting good
enough in the hallway for you to make
that determination answer yes the
hallway was well lit officer gatling's
testimony was the same and he had the
body cam
officer haddon's testimony was the same
the testimony of nurses Debbie Lloyd and
Aaron buram who didn't who like the
police officers did not work for Mr Mr
DAP in fact they they work for Dr Kipper
also the LIE misheard's false
allegations of abuse Isaac Baruch and
Alejandro Romero both testified that
they saw misheard repeatedly and in the
clear life between May 21 2021 which was
the last time
Mr Depp saw her before leaving on the
Hollywood vampires tour the next time he
was to see her was when Miss heard
begged him to come see her in San
Francisco which is hardly the act of a
domestic abuse victim
so we have Isaac Baruch and Mr Romero
saying that they saw misheard repeatedly
in the interval of time between May 21
and May 27th when she obtained the farce
ex-party tro and they saw no marks on
her face and no swelling
uh two witnesses Mr Baruch and Brandon
Patterson saw the video of Miss heard
and her sister Whitney pantomiming the
fake punch after this alleged uh
incident of abuse
Miss heard's former personal assistant
Kate James and several other Witnesses
including Dr David Kipper saw no
violence by Mr Depp and no injuries to
misheard
indeed witness after witness has come
forward to testify that misheard far
from being a domestic figure
representing domestic violence unquote
is in fact a recidivist perpetrator of
domestic violence on Mr Depp uh and and
others we have the testimony uh the
harrowing testimony of Mr Depp himself
who described several witnesses one is
your honor will recall when he was
hiding in the bathroom after escaping
one of her attacks and uh she claims to
have hurt her foot kicking the door Mr
Depp opens the door to see if she's hurt
and then she kicks the door in on him
and punches him
we have the incident of December 15
2015.
when um
Ms hurt threw punches at him wildly at
the back and side of his head
Mr Depp testified that he ducked and
covered to protect his face eventually
he turned around to grab her and stop
her arms from flailing
December 15 in the Bahamas during an
argument Miss heard grabbed a can of
mineral spirits and threw it at Mr
Depp's face striking him in the forehead
bridge and nose era and the jury saw a
photograph of the Brew the bridge on the
bruise of his nose
we have testimony from Mr and and by the
way Tara Roberts who is the manager of
the island confirmed that uh the
incident with the mineral spirits you
have Mr Depp's testimony of what
happened on April 22nd 2016.
uh and we've heard testimony uh today
from Aaron Borum filotti that Mr Depp
was very responsive uh was very sociable
had not uh was not in any way inebriated
that day when misheard says he was and
and she attacked him that
um she attacked him that night as well
and I'm getting to to the end of this
your honor
we have
um
we have Miss heard's own admissions we
have her
um
admitting uh to hitting Mr dapp in her
only uh contention was that she wasn't
punching him she was just hitting him
we have testimony from Travis mcgivern
that uh missed on February 23 2015
misheard through and hit Mr Depp with a
can of Red Bull and then sucker punched
him with a closed fish fist
finally we have uh the rather stunning
testimony of Ben King quite a credible
witness who accompanied misheard on the
flight back from Australia where Miss
heard admits to him in a rhetorical
question quote did you ever totally lose
it on someone you love which was we
would respectfully submit
and admission of her severing the top or
the tip of Mr Depp's figure a finger
finally your honor statement number
three quote I had the rare vantage point
of seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse again
quoting very briefly from page seven of
the Court's opinion letter quote drawing
every Fair inference in plain of favor
the court can fairly include conclude
that defended statement that she saw how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse could reasonably convey to its
recipients that she saw how Mr Depp was
protected by institutions that he abused
her and spoke up against it
uh your honor again we have multiple
testimony from multiple people including
Jack Wiggum and all the others mentioned
that this was a um
a reference to that
um
your honor again the the lies that have
already been exposed that misheard has
told about the charitable contributions
uh the incidents in this case and again
I'll just cite a couple of more the
testimony of Isaac Baruch
when Mr barus saw misheard on June 3
after she'd gone through with the Sham
ex-party
uh
tro
and Mr Bruce was asked did she say
anything in response
and Mr Burris testified yeah
in response to that she meaning misheard
looks at me and said I told Johnny I
don't want anything the lawyers are
making me do all of this and I you know
that's what she said well the lawyers
are making her do all of that and
apparently she wanted the seven million
dollars for herself she even lied about
the final insult left on the marital bed
after her 30th birthday party and it was
quite telling that she admitted to
Starling Jenkins a former United States
Marine
that this was a terrible prank gone awry
well she lied about that too in fact she
said Mr Depp was crazy to even allege
that she could have done such a thing
well she admitted it uh to Mr Jenkins
uh per tronfield
cited earlier Mr Depp
does not have to prove damages because
this is defamation per se in fact these
involve some of the most heinous crimes
any man or woman can be accused of
however he has done so Jack Wiggum
tested yesterday that the impact of the
op-ed was catastrophic on Mr Depp's
personal and professional life
uh that it was a 22.5 million dollar
loss on uh pirate six and another 20
million on others we've had
the um
uh we've had the testimony uh so we had
Mr wiggin testifying as to the 22 and a
half lost on pirate six and another 20
lost on the other films the other Studio
films the indie films and and the other
uh the other ways Mr Depp would have
made income we have Richard Marx's
testimony Douglas spania's testimony and
the testimony of
uh Michael Spindler just this morning
um finally your honor none of Miss
hurt's affirmative defenses which would
include you know her trying to create an
issue of fact on on the title uh can
support a motion to strike as to which
she Bears the burden of proof of her
affirmative defenses quote whether the
defendants have met their burden cannot
be resolved when considering a motion to
strike uh sievert 243 Virginia at 83.
and and just to
um respond to Mr rottenborn's citation
to the lockhovah case which we hadn't
seen until he mentioned it today
I would only note your honor
that defendant admits that she tweeted a
link to the online version of the op-ed
at paragraph 97 of her answer though
again the the admission of exhibit one
is more than enough to survive the
motion to strike and the lakova case at
995 F third 134 holds that republishing
a hyperlink doesn't necessarily start
the statute of limitations not that a
hyperlink
uh cannot be defamatory so with that
your honor we respectfully request that
the court denied the motion to strike in
full and let's hear from his heart
thank you sir thank you your motion
thank you your honor I I can only assume
that Mr Chu wrote that speech for an
audience outside the court because it
didn't really address my arguments I'm
going to focus on what our specific
arguments are for the motion to strike
your honor Mr two spent
almost 30 minutes of the Court's time
talking about the the disputed evidence
of physical abuse in this case which Mr
hasn't even put on her case and and
um
I can tell you she's not the abuser and
if the case moves forward she and her
witnesses will put on even more evidence
of the physical abuse she suffered at
the hands of Mr Depp but that's not the
basis for our emotion right now your
honor he he talks about how Mr debt had
a sworn denial and that that should
count he he we read his testimony he
claims he didn't strike her but again
that's not the basis for our emotion the
basis for emotion is the clear and
Undisputed evidence of non-physical
abuse by his definitions by his
standards by the standards of his expert
there is no dispute that Mr Depp on
abused Amber and therefore if he did it
even one time there is no dispute that
even under their theory of the case the
implication that they want the jury to
draw from the article which again I'm
not arguing for the purposes of today
because under the legal standard I'm not
going to argue that I'm not going to
waste the Court's time with that but
even under their standard the Undisputed
evidence is that Mr Depp did commit
abuse against misheard and therefore
that those first two statements were
false
that's that's our argument on that as to
the headline it's funny Mr Chu
we played you know two or three hours of
an ACLU deposition now he says well that
wasn't our witness it was his witness
your honor he just spent 10 minutes
talking about what Mr Doherty said and
Mr Dougherty testified that the
Washington Post wrote the headline that
is the only evidence your honor I
understand he says well exhibit one has
her name on it exhibit one has her name
on it but the only evidence in this case
about who wrote that headline is Mr
Doherty's testimony it is Undisputed
they could have put anyone else on they
could have called misheard for that
because that was not part of the
stipulation at the at the pre-trial
conference it was only the tweet that we
talked about your honor and they chose
not to do that now misheard will testify
she didn't write that headline so it
wouldn't have helped them but that
they've had three weeks to put on their
case your honor they've controlled the
playing field of evidence there is no
dispute that misheard did not write that
headline
no dispute simply saying well her name
is attached to it that can't overcome
the testimony of the ACLU they call them
a co-conspirator of course Mr Depp chose
not to sue them
um but the testimony of Terence Doherty
that she didn't write that headline that
takes care of the sexual violence
headline your honor and I'm not going to
take up any more of the Court's time
addressing portions of Mr or Mr Mr Chu's
argument that don't go to our motion
unless your honor has any specific
questions but I want to be respectable
thank you sir all right for this motion
I've taken the arguments of council and
last night I reviewed all the evidence
that has been submitted in this matter
so as to the second and third alleged
defamatory statements
um the motion to strike at this juncture
I view the evidence and light most
favorable to the plaintiff and
reasonable inferences from the evidence
to the plaintiff and if there is a
scintilla of evidence that a reasonable
juror could weigh then the matter
survives a motion to strike in this
matter there is evidence in the case
that a jury could weigh that the
statements were made by the defendant
that the statements were about the
plaintiff that the statement was
published that this statement is false
and the defendant made this statement
knowing it to be false or the defendant
made it so recklessly as to amount to a
willful disregard for the truth the
weight of that evidence is up to the
fact finder so the motion to strike is
denied as the statement two and three
the motion to strike as a statement one
I'm going to take under advisement
because if it's not a stipulation I'm
not sure what it is but there seems to
be an agreement that the Tweet of
misheard is part of the plaintiff's
evidence which is not in evidence at
this point so I can't rule on that
statement whether or not it is just a
tweet or if it's some sort of
republication or something I don't know
because I haven't seen it yet so as to
the motion to strike on on statement one
I'm going to take an advisement because
ruling out now it would be premature
because I just don't have that evidence
in the case okay thank you very much all
right since it's 12 30 we only one just
take lunch go and let the jurors go to
lunch and come back at 1 30. does that
sound okay
okay
all right do you want to do it now
okay sure
all right
anything further
130 what towards the recess and 130.
all right
all right thank you
yes oh you have another example perfect
thank you
all right that's 1804. all right thank
you
and you want to approach on the other
issue
or yes
foreign
foreign
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
all right we seated all right the
plaintiff has rested and defense case
your your Witness
you're Don Hughes to the stand Dr Hughes
good afternoon good afternoon
good afternoon thank you your honor will
you please state your name
Dawn Hughes and what is your profession
I am a clinical and forensic
psychologist and where is your practice
located I practice in New York City
what is a clinical psychologist
sure so a clinical psychologist is
somebody who assesses evaluates and
treats individuals who are suffering
from a variety of ailments or problems
that they have in their lives it could
be a major psychiatric disorder and it
could be problems in living clinical
psychologists also participate in
training in education and in research
Ventures
and what is a forensic psychologist
so a forensic psychologist is someone
who applies the science and principles
of clinical psychologists to a
particular legal question at hand
and please describe your background in
terms of your education plea of course
so I received my bachelor degree in
Psychology from Hamilton College which
is in Upstate New York I then received
my Master's Degree and my PhD from Nova
Southeastern University which is in
Florida
I then had to complete my year-long
internship and that was at Yale
University in the school of medicine in
the department of Psychiatry and there I
did two full year rotations I did a year
rotation in the substance abuse
treatment unit and another year rotation
in the West Haven mental health clinic
where we saw individuals suffering from
a wide array of difficulties in
psychiatric illnesses after that I had
to complete my postdoctoral fellowship
which is another year that's required in
order to get licensed and that was back
in New York at Cornell Medical College
in the anxiety and traumatic stress
program there
please describe your training and
experience in Psychology and Trauma
so my experience in trauma has been
predominantly throughout graduate school
I started at a domestic violence program
that was housed within our community
mental health center of the university
and that program we saw both men and
women who were coming through the
program the majority of the men were
court-ordered for um batterers
intervention programs to participate in
mostly group therapy because of their
behavior in intimate partner violence
domestic violence we also
treated the female victims who were
victims of intimate partner violence and
mostly in individual therapy but we did
run some groups there as well
after that uh practicum experience I
went to work at the Veterans
Administration in their outpatient
Psychiatry Clinic
um and in that clinic I treated mostly
this was Florida so they're much older
adults so we saw a lot of Vietnam era
veterans and actually World War II
veterans in that program and a few of
veterans who serve combat in the first
uh Iraq War
um sort of overlapping in that time I
also was the research coordinator for
the child sex abuse Survivors program
and that was also a treatment program
that was housed within that same
Community Mental Health Center and we
saw individuals both men and women who
were coming for treatment to deal with
the consequences the psychological after
effects of having been sexually abused
as a child
after that I completed my internship
when I was at Yale at the substance
abuse program because we know there's a
high concordance a high rate of
trauma-based disorders with substance
abuse I put together a group a woman's
group of female heroin addicts
recovering heroin addicts who also had
either domestic violence or childhood
abuse histories so we did a dual
substance abuse harm reduction model
with the uh the healing from the
traumatic effects of of the violence
that they experienced on my postdoctoral
fellowship I was in the anxiety and
traumatic stress program as the name
sounds we saw individuals who were
suffering from trauma-based disorders
and anxiety mostly late adolescents and
adults men and women from rape sexual
assault violence some were simple
assaults on the streets being mugged and
things of that nature I also did
teaching and training for victim
Services which is New York City's
largest
victim-based organization who runs a lot
of services for victims of domestic
violence and shelter-based programs and
I did the some Education and Training
for them for and teaching for a number
of years
thank you let's talk about your current
occupation what positions do you
currently hold so I currently have a
private practice in in Manhattan and I
also have a faculty position at wall
Cornell Medical College I'm a clinical
assistant professor of psychology in the
department of Psychiatry there this is
what we call on the voluntary faculty
which means you don't get paid but you
participate in bringing in the intern
selecting the interns for that year in
that program I teach I think for the
past seven eight years the ethics
seminar to the interns and also
participate in other didactics that they
have I'm also called upon two sort of
troubleshoot difficult scenarios that
clinicians either trainees or full blood
clinicians might have if there's an
issue of intimate partner violence or
child sex abuse and they don't really
know sort of what to do in that
situation I get consulted to do that
um and then most recently I was part of
our program's coveted Response Team
where in um pretty much March April May
June July 2020 where New York City was
the epicenter we sort of mobilized and
we're really doing psychological first
aid and helping our our hospital-based
workers deal with the stress and the
trauma from seeing so Much Death and
destruction because of covid in in those
first months of of New York City's
coveted wave
what does your independent practice
entail
so my independent practice is
predominantly I say three things
um the bulk is I see individuals in
therapy two and a half days I see people
who come to my office who are mostly
dealing from you know the traumatic
facts of victimization childhood abuse
rape sexual assault sexual harassment
domestic violence and I see these
individuals in therapy I do have a
percentage of individuals who do not
have a trauma history and that's usually
the anxiety disorders that I see they
may have panic disorder or generalized
anxiety disorder or other difficulties
in in just relational difficulties or
problems in living
the second big part of what I do is is
this forensic psychology like I am doing
here today I evaluate individuals who
were involved in in legal matters I
consult with prosecutors and District
Attorneys and U.S attorneys on their
cases and just something that has to do
with the legal system and then the other
smaller percentage is the engagement in
profession activities in the profession
do you have any areas that you
specialize in
yes I specialize in interpersonal
violence and traumatic stress and what
is interpersonal violence so
interpersonal violence is the umbrella
term for when one person does something
violent or abusive toward another and
that includes domestic violence
childhood sexual abuse rape sexual
assault sexual harassment physical
assault all of those type of behaviors
we understand as interpersonal violence
and then traumatic stress is the
consequence of that what happens to
individuals when they experience these
sort of life-altering events these
really adverse life events traumatic
stress is one of the outgrowths and the
psychological consequences that people
have when they've been exposed to these
type of traumas so internet partner
violence rape and sexual assault are
major areas of your focus of practice
that's prepared to say objection leading
sustained injection okay um
I'll just move on what types of patients
do you treat in your private office
so I treat adults mostly men and women
in my practice I sometimes will treat
late adolescents 17 or 18 they'll come
to me usually after a rape or sexual
assault then I'll treat them in in
short-term treatment but mostly adults
who are you know have sustained some
kind of traumatic event in their lives
approximately how many victims of
interpersonal violence have you examined
or personally interviewed over the
course of your career
hundreds upon hundreds
how many years have you been practicing
well I started practicing in graduate
school in 1992 and I was licensed in
1996 so 25 30 years okay are you board
certified yes I am please describe to
the jury what board certification means
and what you are certified in
board certification is the highest
degree of postdoctoral certification
that a psychologist can obtain and I am
board certified in forensic psychology
and that means that I have just amassed
a competency in the area of forensic
psychology
and are you licensed to practice
psychology yes I am yeah and in how many
states are you licensed I'm licensed in
three states in New York North Carolina
and Connecticut and then I have some
temporary licensees in other states as
well
have you published in the area of your
specialization
I have I am not predominantly a
researcher or somebody who writes I'm a
clinician I'm doing direct clinical
service but over the course of my
graduate school and postdoctoral time I
have published some things yes
have you published a
chapter relating to rape and sexual
assault
objection leading
um yes I have rape and sexual assault in
adult women and have you published any
book chapters relating to structured or
clinical assessment of risk or violence
yes I uh co-authored a book chapter
entitled uh this is a structured
clinical assessment of risk and violence
have you given any other trainings or
presentations to mental health
professionals in the area of trauma and
abuse
yes I've given to many trainings uh at
national conferences at legal
conferences for for attorneys for mental
health professionals on understanding
trauma and how trauma may show up in the
courtroom on understanding what a victim
of intimate partner might look violence
might look like of understanding the
difficulties that a rape victim might
have to come into court to testify and
training just regular sort of mental
health professionals on how to
understand trauma how to look for trauma
what does it look like when it comes
into your office how do you treat it how
do you assess it all of those factors
I've done a number of trainings on
have you been invited at any on any
occasions to train attorneys and judges
on trauma and violence
yes I have I was um invited by the
judicial conference to be part of the
training curriculum to train our New
York State uh Supreme Court Justices on
issues of intimate partner violence and
traumatic stress some of the things that
I've just been talking to here about how
to understand what happens in those
situations how to understand the myths
and misconceptions that may be that may
abound in these situations and how you
can sort of more accurately understand
what a victim is talking to you about
and telling you when they come into your
courtroom
uh have you given any presentations to
judicial symposiums on domestic violence
yes I've also been you know contacted by
sometimes judges will have symposiums in
their courtroom they will make a
decision to hold a particular Symposium
on particular topics and I was
um you know asked to come do
presentations for judges on on numerous
occasions
and what if any uh presentations did you
do on understanding women's use of force
in ipv
um that was a recent presentation and I
think that was invited by one of the um
one of the judges of The Office on
domestic violence in New York
um and the title of is when women use
force in situations of intimate partner
violence and my topic was to talk about
the the complexities of that issue and
what does that look like and how can we
differentiate if both people are
fighting how do we know that this is
intimate partner violence so what are
the sort of what is the research tell us
about that how do we understand that and
how can we really accurately assess that
and that was sort of the bulk of what
that training was about
would professional organizations do you
belong to
I belong to a number I belong to the
American Psychological Association which
is the largest body of psychologists in
the United States over here headquarters
in DC I um because it's so big there are
subdivisions of the Trump of American
Psychological Association so I belong to
the division of trauma psychology I
belong to the division of psychology and
the law the division of psychologists
and private practice
I belong to other organizations the
international Society for traumatic
stress studies which as the name says
it's an international Society where we
are interdisciplinary mostly Psychiatry
and psychology researchers and
clinicians to really understand and
further our awareness about trauma and
traumatic stress I belong to the
international Society for trauma and
dissociation I belong to the anxiety
disorders of Association of America I'm
a fellow in the American Board of
forensic psychology
I don't know if I'm forgetting any okay
are any of these specific to
interpersonal violence or trauma
well clearly the trauma division of the
American Psychological Association the
international Society for traumatic
stress studies and the international
Society for trauma and dissociation and
then also the anxiety disorders of
Association continues to talk about
trauma because prior to this new DSM-5
it was PTSD was originally categorized
under the anxiety disorders so there are
still colleagues and researchers in the
anxiety disorders organizations who talk
about PTSD and Trauma
do you hold any leadership roles in
these organizations
yes I am currently the president-elect
of the trauma division of the American
Psychological Association that is an
elected position you have to be elected
by our membership
um and now I serve uh as with the
presidential Trio so there's three of us
you serve with the immediate past
president the current president and the
president-elect so it's a three-year
term and what we try to do is continue
to disseminate best practices and Trauma
psychology and also interface with the
larger American Psychological
Association organization to continue to
disseminate best practices and have just
a voice for trauma psychology with our
larger body and and policy making I've
been involved in the trauma psychology
executive board since its Inception I
was a founding member of that Division I
served as a membership chair a program
chair and awards chair I was the APA
Council of Representatives which means I
was also elected to serve a three-year
term and sit on the governance Board of
APA representing the division of trauma
psychology so I've been very actively
involved in the trauma division
and what is the division of trauma
psychology
so the division of trauma psychology or
psychologists who who come together who
want to disseminate best practices in
trauma psychology we want to make sure
that we have our finger on the pulse of
research and evidence-based
interventions for people who are
struggling with traumatic events that
have happened to them
okay
have you served in leadership positions
of other professional organizations
yes I was there's a New York city-based
organization it's called the women's
mental health Consortium and that's also
an interdisciplinary organization it's
psychology Psychiatry nursing social
work and this was formed in order to
give women sort of a referral base and
more information about mostly like
reproductive Psychiatry we know that
certain difficulties and um
psychological difficulties that you have
can erupt when you're pregnant or
postpartum so we wanted to have a number
of resources available to women in the
New York City area I was a membership
chair there for a number of years and
then I was the president of that
organization
I think 2009 to 2017 I don't have my CV
but I think that's about right
why is participation in professional
organizations important in your field
well it's important to me because I do
believe very much in service I do
believe very much in giving back I do
believe that it's important as a
psychologist who believe strongly in in
trauma psychology and helping people
that I can be part of a voice at the
table part of that push to get policy
and understanding especially with the
insurance companies to make sure that
people are getting you know the
appropriate care that they deserve so
it's something that just has always been
part of my life in varying degrees and
as a psychologist I feel like it's a you
know a very rewarding part of my job
do you attend professional conferences
yes I do typically multiple times a year
of course covered through a little bit
of a wrench in that since some things
are virtual but yes I routinely attend
conferences
and why do you think that's important
it's important to stay abreast of
developments in the field it's important
to meet with your colleagues across the
country and see what they're doing and
what they're hearing and what's working
and what's not working so when you're
when you're at a conference and
somebody's presenting new or novel
research then you can take that
information and that bring that back to
your clients and bring that back to my
forensic work so it absolutely enhances
the work that I do have you ever been
qualified to testify in the field of
psychology as an expert witness yes I
have how many times
I was first qualified in 1998 so since
then
um about 50 times okay and how often in
that 50 times has the specialty been in
interpersonal violence and traumatic
stress
probably more than half
have you ever worked for or testified
for the prosecution in criminal matters
like the District Attorney's Office U.S
attorney's Office yes I have frequently
do you testify for both sides in
lawsuits plaintiffs and defendants yes I
do have you ever worked on other cases
that didn't go to trial many okay
okay have you ever found an individual
that you evaluated did not suffer from
the effects of interpersonal violence or
PTSD frequently
have you ever not been qualified in
court where you have been proffered to
qualify as an expert in the court
no
your honor I would at this time move to
qualify Dr Hughes as an expert in
forensic psychology with the
specialization in interpersonal violence
and traumatic stress all right any
objection
no objection to qualifying her as an
expert in forensic psychology
psychology with a specialization in
interpersonal violence and traumatic
stress any objection no all right so
moved
thank you your honor
Dr Hughes please tell the jury what
domestic violence intimate partner
violence means
sure so I'm probably going to be
interchanging the language domestic
violence and interpersonal violence and
for purposes here these are the same
thing
um so intimate partner violence is a
pattern of manipulation fear and
coercive control that happens within an
intimate relationship it constitutes
using a variety of abusive behaviors and
that can be physical violence sexual
violence psychological aggression
emotional abuse stalking or surveillance
behaviors and economic abuse the abusive
behaviors occur over time not all at
once and they're also interspersed with
very normal times times without violence
times with love and happiness and it's
this interpositioning of the violence
with the love and the abute with the
love and the care that makes it very
difficult for a victim to extricate
herself from that situation and from
that relationship
and what would you say is the
overarching dynamic of these
relationships so the overarching dynamic
is the abuse of power and control of one
person wanting to have dominance in that
relationship say over most things that
the couple or that the victim does or
does not do
you tell the jury what coercive control
means
so coercive control is a tactic of
victimization the goal of it is to
establish dominance what coercive
control does is that it imposes negative
consequences for non-compliance with
your partner's expectations or demands
and what that does is it erodes away at
the victim's autonomy and her
independence
what is physical violence
so physical violence is when one person
uses their body against the body of
another with the intent to cause injury
or harm that can be push shove slap kick
punch beat up meaning multiple types of
physicality in one instance
throw slam into a wall push into
something hard that you could hurt
yourself clearly use of a weapon would
be a physically violent act as well
the size and strength matter between the
parties
yes very much so um this is very well
documented in the literature about
violence and abuse in relationships and
and that's just um that's just physics
that's just proportional force that if a
185 pound man is going to push a 120
pound woman that's going to feel quite
different than 120 pound woman pushing
185 pound man and it's just about
proportional force and the size and
strength differential and that is why
specifically if you look at a wrestling
or boxing they match weight classes and
they do that for a reason because they
know that it's not fair if somebody is
bigger and stronger than the other so
it's certainly not the only Factor but
it is a factor that one has to consider
if a relationship is violent
what is psychological aggression
so psychological aggression is threats
and the imposition of threats with the
intent to control someone's Behavior so
it's doing it's doing a threat so that
you will modify your behavior and do
what your partner wants some
psychological aggression techniques are
intimidation
um slamming your hand on a on a table
punching a wall throwing something and
mumbling under your mouth cursing
screaming sort of these these high
emotional balance type of activities
that can cause a victim to feel afraid
and feel intimidated and then if there
has been an act of physical violence
where that contingency has already been
established that this person your
partner has said okay I will not only
have the ability to use violence against
you I also have the willingness to do it
the intimidating tactics take on greater
flavor they take on greater salience
they need more because you know what
could be coming down the pike
what is the emotional abuse
so emotional abuse functions to
denigrate a person's sense of self-worth
and their their self
perception it's about name-calling being
very mean-spirited putting yourself down
using gender-based language that's
offensive racial slurs all types of
behaviors to really make a person feel
less than they actually should
and what is sexual abuse so sexual abuse
in an intimate relationship functions to
establish dominance and disestablish
power what it is simply in the
psychological and psychiatric
communities is forcing someone to do
something sexual against your will when
you do not want to
um it can be forced sex either forced
vaginal oral anal sex and be forced to
engage in any other type of sexual act
that you may not want to do and when I
say force it doesn't mean it has to have
physical Force there's a lot of
psychologically coercive tactics that
are used that many times when violence
has already been established in the
relationship the victim often feels that
she can't say no for fear of reprisal
for fear of retaliation for saying no to
those acts so sexual abuse you know does
happen an intimate partner relationships
a lot of people don't want to talk about
it and they don't want to ask about it
because it makes people very
uncomfortable is digital penetration of
the vagina sexual abuse
action leading what if any role does
digital penetration of the vagina play
in sexual abuse
if it is non-consensual then it is
abusive what if any penetration of
inanimate objects into the vagina plays
a role in sexual abuse again the
operative word is consensual if you are
not consenting to those acts then it is
sexually abusive
is there a distinction between sexual
violence and sexual abuse
not really sexual violence is a term of
art it is the overarching umbrella that
we in the psychological and psychiatric
communities talk about so if we are
looking at our Diagnostic and
statistical manual and say what are the
traumas that could cause PTSD it's
listed as sexual violence so it's an
umbrella term that allows us to
understand it could be childhood sexual
abuse it could be a rape a sexual
assault it can be sexual abuse in an
intimate relationship so it's really
just an overarching term
um that we use in the field
so it doesn't mean I think people often
mistake it to mean that when you are
being sexually abused that someone's
punching you or someone's hitting you or
someone's doing something like that
because you hear the violent it does not
mean that that could happen but that
term does not require that nor does it
mean that
what are stocking or surveillance
behaviors
so stalking and surveillance behaviors
are a common tactic of of typically men
um who use violent behaviors in an
intimate relationship what they do is
they allow the woman to know that
wherever she is wherever she goes he's
going to know I'm going to maybe look at
your phone see who you're talking to
track you won't find my iPhone look at
your Instagram look at your emails you
know really having a way of knowing all
of the personal information about you
and what that does it again erodes the
victim's autonomy and it roads her sense
of privacy she doesn't feel that
wherever she can go that's somewhere
he's not going to be part of her life in
an in a very objectionable way sometimes
there's the pop-ins they'll show up at
places that they're not supposed to be
and that we don't want them to be just
as a way of checking sometimes they'll
have friends or family check up on their
Partners to make sure where they are
what time did you get home but you
didn't turn off your phone at this time
but you came in the door this time like
all of the sort of constant questioning
and interrogation about an individual's
whereabouts
what about economic abuse what is that
so economic abuse is a way to again
continue to maintain control over your
intimate partner sometimes it's
withholding information about the
finances of not letting you have access
to the finances if you can't have access
to a credit card or a checking account
or you know Apple pay on your phone then
you're rendered usually much more
economically dependent on your partner
and that limits tangible options for you
for individuals where that sort of
tangible options isn't there we see the
economic abuse or the economic
restriction when one partner refuses to
share any information about the funds so
it's not like I can't go shopping
because I won't have money but I don't
have any decision making in our family
money I don't have any idea of what
we're doing in our family
vis-a-vr finances so it's a way of
definitely keeping that very separate
and not in a consensual some couples
make that choice one person does all the
money that's is fine but when it doesn't
come from a place of of consensual
Choice making it can be abusive
so
described a number of these abusive
behaviors are all of them present in
every uh domestic violence relationship
right no they're not all present in
everyone and that's why it's very
important to do a thorough assessment of
a relationship that may be mired in
violence to see which ones are present
and which ones have a great impact in
the relationship which ones are sort of
making the structure of this
relationship
after a sexual assault in an intimate
relationship how might a victim in those
circumstances interact with her partner
so so this is one of the myths that
people say well if she was sexually
assaulted by her partner she would have
just left and nothing could be further
from the truth that's not what happens
um especially when it's your your
husband or your boyfriend or your
partner so what women do is they they
bury it they compartmentalize it they
they put it away they avoid it because
then they continue to to reach out for
the kind and the loving man that they
got into this relationship with you know
the problem is that it does fester
belief and cause is more sort of
psychological distress in the victim
what if any role can shame or
humiliation play in this coercive
dynamic so so that's one of the emotions
that um the the victim is usually trying
to to suppress and compartmentalize and
avoid and put away
um one of the most you know frequently
felt feelings after something so
incredibly humiliating and violating is
shame and shame is a very sort of
difficult emotion for people to have to
live with and to have to experience and
then a lot of times what we see in in
these relationships especially ones
where sexual assault is perpetrated
there's typically the emotional abuse as
well so now if you'll be your called
names like a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and easy
and fat and you're feeling the shame
from the sexual assault that just
happened it sort of acts as a
compounding effect and it sort of kind
of slowly deteriorates the psychological
functioning of the victim and where
they're just really trying to get back
to the good guy get the good guy to come
back but they're suffering these simple
comes underneath
what about intimidation what role does
intimidation play in the coercive
control dynamic
I mean intimidation is one of the the
huge
factors that we see in coercive control
again the goal is to get your partner to
do what you want them to do and if
you've established that you can use
violence and other sexual violence and
physical violence slamming your hands on
a table throwing a glass breaking a door
you know throwing anything causing a fit
yelling and screaming you know that can
rise the fear level in in a victim that
she may modify her behavior quicker and
he might not need to use physical
violence because he's already
established that that fear is there
what if any role could write an obscene
messages
play in being considered an intimidating
Behavior
objection leading
I said what if any your honor overruled
I mean certainly writing obscene
messages to your partner could
absolutely be an intimidating Behavior
what if any role does emotional abuse or
degradation play in the Dynamics
so emotional abuse and degradation as I
stated before functions to decrease your
sense of self-worth it decreases your
sense of agency it makes you feel bad
about yourself and when you feel bad
about yourself you're less likely to
actualize and see options for leaving
you're so sort of mired in in this
Dynamic of abuse that you come sometimes
to believe the bad things that the
person is telling you about so you know
maybe I am not talented and fat and lazy
and stupid and it interferes with that
ability to problem solve and figure out
you know can I get out of this
relationship and sometimes you feel you
don't even deserve to get out of the
relationship when the abuse is so
chronic and so repetitive
what role does surveillance as a means
of control play in that dynamic
so surveillance Jackson leading
so surveillance functions to let the
victim know wherever you are there I am
um so it makes her feel
um not secure in her movement feeling
that she has to restrict her movement
her movement is not hers alone it
usually increases hyper vigilance it
increases fear it increases the need to
to for yourself to Mark where you've
been and what you've done so that you
can go back and prove it to your partner
because you know that there is going to
be an interrogation later when this this
pattern has been established show
receipts you know show me your iPhone
where were you what's your Google
location at you know those are some
types of surveillance behaviors that
puts the victim very much on edge and
increases that level of anxiety and
trepidation
what role does possessive jealousy play
in these relationships so possessive
jealousy is a very
um difficult dynamic in intimate partner
violence it's very common in situations
of coercive control it's rooted in in
possession that the gentleman feels that
he can possess her and that he can have
her whenever he wants is very possessive
Dynamic but the accusations the problem
is when you make the accusations the
woman's forced to refute the accusations
so they're continuing in this Dynamic
where she's trying to prove I didn't do
what you said this didn't happen and
then unfortunately sometimes it
escalates because the the ban is not
taking the no for an answer because if
this is a a preservative obsessive
pattern that's very difficult to
penetrate that often these type of
conversations lend themselves to
physical and sexual violence
does this Dynamic happen overnight
no it doesn't happen overnight it
happens over time and we don't um you
know woman doesn't get into a
relationship with a man who's beating
her up and sexually assaulting her and
calling her names and doing all that um
you know she gets into the relationships
for all the right reasons just like we
all get into relationships for love for
companionship for kindness for a future
but then slowly you know all of these
behaviors start to take form and I
always say it's sort of like sucking the
oxygen out of the room and then before
you know it you're suffocating
so and and that brings me to my next
question what uh what role do physical
abuse and coercive tactics play
interspersed with normalcy and positive
moments
objection compound
not sustained objection okay uh
I'll figure this out some way
um what role does Love and normalcy play
in these Dynamics you've been describing
objection compound
thank you
so love and normalcy are almost always
in these relationships that you know
when you are in a lull and the violence
is not happening you're back to sort of
the the loving man that you wanted the
person who you wanted to be with
um and when you pair sort of this um
this violent Dynamic physical violence
sexual violence with love and attachment
it creates a trauma Bond it creates a
psychological bond an emotional
dependency is created so it makes it
very difficult for the victim of the
abuse to extricate herself from that
relationship and for her to even believe
frankly I mean that takes a lot of time
to even believe that she can and that
she should
and what if any role does that Dynamic
you've described have in the victim
thinking they can fix the problem
so what do we know from the research the
research with working with battered men
who come into treatment is that the only
person who can change the abuse is the
abuser so no matter what the tactics
that the woman uses she's trying to do
all these different things to fix him to
have him not be violent to have him not
be sexually violent have them not be
obsessively jealous and all those things
don't change his behavior because it's
up to him to change his behavior and
this was played out a million times in
in the batteries intervention groups
that I led and the the men would tell us
it doesn't matter what she does I don't
care
um so the problem is is that the woman
continues to think that she can fix it
and yet she can't but she's the one
who's then rendered sort of helpless and
hopeless because everything that she's
trying to do is failing
what is the cycle of violence
so the cycle of violence is one way to
describe this domestic violence pattern
typically what we see in the cycle can
be different in a variety of
relationships but typically what we see
is in the first phase is sort of
multiple three to four phases in the
first phase there's a tension building
phase you're sort of starting to feel
that that apprehension he may be
throwing his papers on the table a
little more he may be slamming the
fridge door a little more he may be
mumbling under his mouth a little more
he may grab a glass a little more
forcefully than he normally is
and then there's the incident phase then
there's the blow up where the violence
the abuse the screaming the sexual
violence or the physical violence all
that occurs
then we come to the Contrition phase
I'm sorry I didn't mean it it wasn't me
I'm not going to do it again the
promises for change and then we sort of
slide into the calm phase where you know
this isn't going to happen again I'm
back to stable ground I'm going to live
in this place this sort of honeymoon
place you know the problem in the calm
phase is we often see
the rationalizations and the
justifications for the behavior it's not
like typically the man is taking full
responsibility for what he did but it's
calm because there's no you know
violence and no sort of tension at that
moment
um and then it recurs and then it recurs
um so you're stuck in this vicious cycle
of trying to figure out how can I be
with this man who hurts me
and yet I love him so much
and what if anything does the term love
bomb mean
so so the love bombing is um it's more
of the colloquial term for for the
younger folks here but you know where
you shower someone with with affection
and love you know in this Contrition and
calm phase where you know your
everything about you is special you're
the best thing in the world I'm never
going to do anything to hurt you again I
would never let anyone hurt you and it
could be selling sending flowers and
buying gifts or going on trips or your
favorite restaurants
um and that is you know a way of where
the man is trying to make those amends
um and then it gets the woman hooked so
they get hooked on the kindness they get
hooked on the love they don't get hooked
on the abuse I've never met one woman in
the hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
that I've evaluated who was not
concerned about the violence they're all
concerned about the violence
but they go for the love
so
in in your experience with with these
dynamics that you've described does the
victim ever yell at her partner
absolutely why
we know from the research that women use
verbal and physical acts of aggression
in these relationships that's not
uncommon this has been researched for
five decades and a woman May yell at her
partner because she's angry and it anger
is a very normal emotion to having been
abused she can also be afraid
but they don't have to be mutually
exclusive we can absolutely as human
beings feel two or three or four
different motions at once
um you know people do often say to me oh
she would never yell at him if she knew
he was going to hit her
and that's not true that's just patently
not true that doesn't that's not
supported in the research and that's not
supported in my clinical practice you
know the problem is is there's a classic
double bind and the violence has been so
normalized in the relationship now she
gets hit if she does you she gets it if
she doesn't yell so for women who feel
at certain moments that they need to
preserve some sense of their autonomy
and their independence and stand up for
themselves they will yell and they will
fight back even though the risk of
violence is there so it doesn't mean
that she's not afraid and that she's not
concerned about the violence and it
doesn't mean she doesn't also use
placating and compliance strategies most
of the time as well
uh does does in the cases that you have
and in your experience
um does the abuse typically take place
in front of others
no I mean this is classically what we
talk about behind closed doors most of
the intimate partner violence the
domestic violence happens you know in
the privacy of your own home so
sometimes we see the remnants of it the
after effects or or victims talk to
their friends or family about it but
very rarely are you seeing it happen the
actual blow-up phase happen in the
middle of witnesses and other people
what's the term bystander effect mean
so bystander effect means what happens
when people are aware that domestic
violence is happening what happens when
they're aware even if they're not seeing
it
um that it could be happening and what
happens is we know that it's very
difficult for people to to stand up and
say something it's very difficult
especially in situations where there's a
larger community of folks and the person
who perhaps is perpetrating the abuse is
the leader of that Community it becomes
very difficult to go up against that to
go up against the sort of the head
honcho of the community
people are very fearful of losing their
jobs I've seen this time and time again
in in the cases that I've worked on
either the Boy Scout cases or the clergy
abuse cases you know all of those type
of cases where the USA Gymnastics where
when we go back and we look we see
people new but the secretary doesn't
want to lose her job she schizophy the
guy who you know checks you in he
doesn't want to lose his job because he
has a mortgage to pay
so people are quiet and they don't say
anything you know and then other people
are are very
um it's a very worrisome dynamic they
don't want to put their foot out there
if they're wrong and maybe I didn't see
it right or I don't really know what
happened I certainly am not going to
jeopardize my job if I don't really know
what happened behind closed doors even
if I see a trash room or a bruise and
then people still believe it's a family
matter you know it's between Amber and
Johnny let them figure it out you know
I'm not going to get in the middle so
those are dynamics that happen
what's the objection yeah motion to
strike
what's the objection
we identified two names in the answer
uh overall excellent thank you
did you finish your answer yes I believe
so okay what about Mutual abuse what is
that what role does that play
so mutual abuse isn't really a term of
art that we use what we look at is
situational couple violence
and intimate partner violence and when
we look at situational couple bonds that
really does characterize the majority of
types of violence and abuse that happens
in relationships that's when a couple
gets out of hand they may push shove
slap yell say some things that they
don't want and it's not that those
behaviors are okay but those are sort of
what the our larger sale community-based
studies say happens in these
relationships that's distinguished from
intimate partner violence what I'm
talking to you about that has this
consolation of symptoms and is rooted in
the abuse of power and control
is there research that addresses this
Mutual abuse
yeah this research that addresses what
does
um gender symmetry look like male and
female are they the same
um and they're certainly as I said
research that on the
um the lower end types of violent
behaviors push shove slap
you know we may see similar rates
between men and women in psychological
aggression yelling name-calling putting
down in some of our big Community scale
studies we may see similar rates of
perpetration in those behaviors but then
there are you know other situations
where we don't have gender Symmetry and
what the research talks about very
clearly is you have to examine context
you have to examine the differential of
power and control and coercive control
in the relationship to make a full
determination
do women use violence in relationships
yeah absolutely again we've known this
for five decades in our research we've
been studying this since the 70s and
when we look at what happens you know
women do report their use of violence
um the majority of violence that we do
see is what we call reactive violence or
self-defensive violence or sometimes
violence that's perpetrated
independently of of an assault of
something that's going on but mostly
that when the partner begins to come
violent then she may become violent and
fight back and that's not an uncommon
Dynamic that if somebody is being pushed
or shoved or hit that a person would
fight back that has been established in
the research and what if any effect does
that have on changing the power dynamics
or the structure well you have to find
out does it does her use of violence
change the overarching power structure
of coercive control and violence and
abuse in this relationship and you have
to examine those variables to see does
it or does it not
can men be victims of intimate partner
violence
absolutely certainly we know that we
have to be careful of gendered
stereotypes we can't go in and think oh
only the woman is the victim or and only
the man is the perpetrator that just
does not comport with the research we
know that the research also shows that
we can have domestic violence and
same-sex relationships my very first
case was a same-sex domestic violence
homicide in Brooklyn
um so I've been that was in 1998 so I've
been examining and treating individuals
in a variety types of violent contexts
so we have to be careful that that bias
doesn't get in our way when we're
evaluating a particular situation in a
particular case
that said we do know that there still
are differences you know in a
heterosexual couple in a male female
diet the research still is clear that
there are differences men still
perpetrate more severe acts of violence
women are still more likely to be
injured they are much more like likely
to suffer sexual violence at the hands
of their partner they're more likely to
be intimidated afraid and they're much
more likely to be killed so we know that
those differences exist but we do
examine you know in those individual
circumstances knowing that either one
could be a perpetrator or a victim
so how are you
determine whether a relationship is a
situational violence or intimate partner
violence
so I thoroughly examine all of those
other variables I look for the coercive
control who holds the power in the
situation who's able to say no who makes
the decisions what are the consequences
if you don't follow the decisions of
your partner is there sexual violence is
there intimidation and fear are there
statistical factors that are associated
with severe and lethal domestic violence
so there's a lot of data that we have in
the field that we can use to assess a
particular relationship and really find
out what's going on
does alcohol and substance use cause
people to be violent
oh it certainly doesn't cause people to
be violent we have plenty of people who
can be you know struggling with
substance abuse and addiction and
they're not violent but when you have a
substance abuse and addiction
and you perpetrate domestic violence it
does create a a much more disastrous
effect it is a co-occurring variable and
we know that also from the research that
the majority of the women will report
that when their partner is drinking the
physical violence goes up so a lot of
the times when he's physically violent
is when he's been consuming drugs or
alcohol
when he's not consuming drugs and
alcohol and he's not violent those other
behaviors continue to persist the
coercive control the surveillance the
obsessive jealousy the possessiveness
the psychological abuse those usually
persist but the alcohol can just throw
lighter fluid on a flame in a situation
of domestic violence
is there research that looks at how
women hope with the violence and abuse
in their relationships yes there is
please tell me about it what does it say
so there's been a lot of research to
talk about what do women do that's the
question that everyone wants to know why
doesn't she just leave and in asking
that question why doesn't she just leave
we actually are able to say well let me
tell you what she does do and and what
the research shows is women do a lot of
things in that relationship so sort of
three main categories one of the formal
responses the formal things that she
does call the police participate in
prosecution of your partner go see a
therapist go to a shelter go to a
hospital these are sort of the very
formal strategies that women can use
then they're the informal strategies and
that's talking with your best friend
talking with your mom talking with your
friends trying to get that emotional
support from your social network but the
most common one of these personal
strategies and the personal strategies
are really talking with your partner
they're trying to fix the relationship
from within the confines of the
relationship you know trying to get him
to go to counseling try to get him to go
to church try to get him to understand
his ways try to get him to get into AAA
or sober counseling or harm reduction
model to help with his addiction
compliance with his demands anticipating
his demands all these coping strategies
that are sort of you know embedded
within that intimate relationship
let's talk about the calling the police
is that a common response
it's not a common response uh many women
do not want to call the police on their
Partners uh you know using criminal
justice interventions um in crimes of
women and children are the least likely
to be called into law enforcement and
most of the time when the police are
called it's because a particular
incident has got out of hand and she
feels unsafe and the only way that she
feels I can get this incident to end and
stop is by calling law enforcement
and if police are called does the woman
typically participate in the prosecution
I mean this has been a a problem and a
difficulty for prosecutors across the
country
um since I've been doing this work I'm
actually frequently called by the
prosecutor to testify about a fact
pattern because the victim won't come in
and testify so dropping restraining
orders not participating in the
prosecution is a very common dynamic in
in situations of intimate partner
violence domestic violence and and what
we know and what we know from our law
enforcement data and colleagues is that
when you get when when you get that
9-1-1 call they're very specifically
trained to say that's likely not the
first episode the chances are there have
been more severe episodes before you get
this call so you can't go on the scene
and think that this is the first episode
of violence and that's why a thorough
assessment is supposed to be done when
police officers arrive on the scene so
usually that episode that calls the
police is just meant to stop that
incident in that moment to get sense of
safety but most women don't want to
participate and go forward with
restraining orders
why do women in violent relationships
stay in the relationship when the man's
hurting them
I mean they stay for all the reasons we
talked about in the cycle of violence
they say for for the loving man they say
for the man who's kind they say for the
man they decided to marry and had hope
and promises for their future so there's
a lot of sort of love and attachment is
why they're connected to their partner
some people stay because they have
economic reasons and they don't have
tangible resources to leave some people
have children in common and they don't
want to deprive their children of a
father so some people fear retaliation
if I leave I'm going to get seriously
hurt and frankly the statistics bear it
out the most dangerous time for a woman
is when she's leaving that relationship
her likelihood of being killed grows
substantially at that moment so leaving
sometimes isn't a best strategy staying
keeps her safe so there's usually a
whole Mo a multitude of factors of why a
woman decides to stay in the
relationship and again as I said
previously it doesn't mean she's on
concerned about the violence just she
hasn't figured out a way out yet
what if any role does emotional
attachment and love play in that
that's you know probably the biggest one
is that you you have this we talked
about that trauma bond that has
developed that psychological attachment
to your partner
um you don't want to leave him you
you've connected with him on so many
other levels that giving that up just
feels like a threat to your integrity
you're just sort of and a threat to his
because you're just so intertwined and
attached what if any role does Hope and
optimism play
hope and optimism are really what keeps
victims alive in these situations that's
what gets them going from one episode to
the next to get up the next day and
maybe he's not going to drink today
maybe it's going to be on his good side
maybe he's going to come home and not
disappear for three days continuing to
hope that some type of change is coming
down the pike
now you mentioned lethality a little
earlier can you please explain to us
what that means
so lethality is
um means death means Fatality and we
have very well validated instruments and
data that looks at what factors happen
in a relationship where a woman ends up
dead
um and we do that through looking
retrospectively saying you know here's
you know this person ended up
um dead killed by her partner in a
homicide and let's see what factors were
there so that we can work at preventing
it
um it's very methodologically sound over
different case controlled designs over
multiple cities viewed by the FBI and
law enforcement so these are a number of
factors that tell us that somebody is in
a very dangerous situation so some of
the factors are an increase of frequency
and severity of the violence threats to
kill choking Behavior sexual assault
obsessive and possessive jealousy
controlling Behavior the perpetrators
use and abuse of substances alcohol and
substances the perpetrators threatening
of suicide himself right those are some
of the top factors and there are more
that are are very very dangerous when we
hear that and we hear a woman is in a
situation where those are present then
we are moving out of a situational
couple violence
destroying property and destroying
property destruction of property
personal property is also one of the
risk factors for danger and Fatality and
what if any role does leaving
threatening messages play that's also a
risk factor for for lethality
what are the psychological and traumatic
effects that such interpersonal violence
has on victims objection compound
psychological and traumatic effects are
kind of interchangeable sustain the
objection what are the psychological
effects that such interpersonal violence
has on victims so these have also been
well researched and they are wide and
varied we see depression and depressive
disorders sometimes with suicidality we
see anxiety and anxiety disorders a lot
of stress we see post-traumatic stress
disorder we see substance abuse and
substance abuse disorders we see trust
difficulties and difficulties in
interpersonal relationships as a result
we see a lot of Shame and humiliation we
see anger and rage a whole sleep
disruption a whole host of difficult
psychological consequences having
sustained a relationship of intimate
partner violence what if any world is
low self-esteem play well low
self-esteem is a very common after
effect and and that you know when you're
embedded in the relationship it also
makes it just very difficult for you to
climb your way out
what is emotional dysregulation
emotional dysregulation so it's a dys
dysregulation is when you sort of don't
feel that you have control of your
emotions you feel like you're
fluctuating you know from one to the x
is one to the next it's not the same as
a bipolar disorder it you know can
happen in short moments that you know
it's really because your central nervous
system is so out of Haywire from being
exposed to so many traumatic events that
you may feel things deeply and with a
short trigger and in a very quick time
in your experience is there a particular
way victims of intimate partner violence
remember the violence they endured well
memory for traumatic events is something
that has been well researched sometimes
people have what we call dissociative
Amnesia where because of the physical or
psychic pain of what they're going
through a portion of the memory either
gets blocked or can't get retrieved
whether it's stored or retrieval we're
not really sure
but most of the times the memory is
really about when you have multiple
repeated events of the same type of
thing so if you are abused multiple
times and the abuse is very similar it's
very common for the victim to lose
discrete details of a particular
incident they may not retain the memory
for the complete incident and that might
not be to dissociative Amnesia that just
might mean to forgetting because you
have so many chronic events that have
happened to you
are there common myths or misperceptions
about domestic violence
they're all right I hope I've dispelled
some of them here already but I mean the
myths you know certainly are that women
are Meek are passive or you know just
sitting there and letting the abuse
happen that women don't fight back that
women don't yell back that they some old
ones that they like the violence they're
not concerned about the violence that if
it was really bad she really would have
left if it was really bad she really
would have told the police all of those
myths and misconceptions
um that just don't comport with the
research
or they're also myths about trauma
survivors what what house trauma
survivors present
yes there are and what we say is um you
know how
lay people think someone who suffered a
traumatic event is supposed to act
um so in the immediate aftermath of a
trauma people think oh they should be
hysterical and abreacting and emotional
all over the place and that's typically
not the first reaction of a trauma
Survivor the first reaction is you know
suppression emotional numbing emotional
constriction how do I get through this
you know women who are beaten they get
up the next morning they get their kids
dressed they get them to school they go
to work they do a presentation in their
office they go on with life the most
normal thing that a person does who've
experienced trauma is to get up and try
to be normal they're striving for that
all the time so sometimes if you see
somebody who is more emotionally
constricted looks maybe stoic looks like
they're not feeling it doesn't mean that
they're not having internal reactions we
say this in the field of Clinical
Psychology all the time time the inside
doesn't match the outside what you're
seeing on the outside may not match
what's going on for the person inside
because they have to be so controlled
because the fear is is that if I let out
a little of this emotion I'm not going
to be able to put the floodgates back on
it's just going to be too overwhelming
and that's true for people who are
involved in litigation and also true for
my private patients who are even though
they're coming to me for help they try
very very cleverly to not want to feel
the difficult emotions of the trauma
that they experienced
and is it is it uh also possible that
they can look very friendly and smile
and laugh and things like that yeah yeah
and compound
sustain uh what if any uh please
describe some of the ways that a victim
can hide that as you're you've just
testified to we call that the appearance
of normalcy the appearance of Competency
right that and it doesn't mean that
they're not it doesn't mean that they're
not normal and that they're not
competent but it doesn't give you a
bird's eye into their inner experience
and that's what we do in the we say in
the rooms in the rooms of therapy where
we really help people deal with that
that they keep to themselves but yes
someone can be smiling and happy it
doesn't mean that they're not suffering
inside
is there a single profile that fits all
women in domestic violence situations no
is there a single profile of a man who
perpetrates intimate partner violence no
your honor I'm at a point of moving to a
new topic topic area I don't know what
your honor wants to do because I know we
switched the launcher out I'm perfectly
happy to keep going but if this was a
good stopping point we could make that
for their break
all right let's go ahead and take our
afternoon break for 15 minutes okay just
do not discuss the case and do not do
any outside research okay
a little early
all right and Dr Houston's you are
testifying please do not discuss your
testimony including the attorneys at
this point okay yes all right we'll come
back at 3 15 then okay thank you
thank you
foreign
all right
all right are you ready for the jury yes
you're okay
foreign
all right all right are you seated all
right your next question
thank you
Dr Hughes did there come a time when you
conducted a forensic psychological
evaluation of Amber Heard
and please tell the jury what a forensic
psychological evaluation is
can you turn it on at the bottom base
okay
um a forensic psychological evaluation
is an evaluation that is conducted for
the courts to answer a particular legal
question it contains multiple Parts
misheard is not a client of mine she's
never been in therapy with me I'm not
under my clinical care it is an
objective evaluation to determine a
particular legal question forensic
evaluation follows a methodology that
what we say it's it's a multi-method
multi-hypothesis driven methodology
which means I look at a variety of
different documents and data using
multiple hypothesis it's not just one
hypothesis one theory of the case you're
going in looking to see you know what
possibly could be going on here and then
you use the data to arrive at that
opinion you look for consistency across
the data to arrive at that opinion and
the forensic psychological evaluation
has many parts it has the clinical
interview part a structured or
semi-structured clinical interview where
I'm asking Miss Heard lots of things
about her life both before Mr Depp and
after it involves a psychological
testing component of the evaluation
which allows me to do a good broad scan
of different symptomatologies that
people might have in their lives as well
as to have indicators of how she
approached the test is she defensive is
she malingering is she feigning is she
exaggerating it gives me indications
about how she approached the evaluation
I review a number of documents medical
records psychological records the text
the audio all the different things that
we've had in this case and then I
conduct collateral interviews
so Dr Hughes do you just to be clear do
you assume everything uh the victim
reports is true when you conduct these
examinations no of course not I always
approach a forensic evaluation with a
healthy dose of skepticism
um with any forensic evaluation there
there exists a motivation that the
individual may be telling you something
that is not accurate it doesn't mean
that that's there but you have to
control for that
um and know that you're looking for
again what does the data tell you the
external data about what the person is
also telling you the forensic evaluation
follow a standard methodology or was it
specific to Ms heard no this is my
standard methodology that I would use
with any individual who's in a forensic
matter and I would be called to evaluate
them
when did you meet with Amber Heard
okay so I met with Miss heard um for a
total of about 29 hours I met with her
for the first time in September 2019 I
saw her for four visits in live in my
New York City office I that's about 21
22 hours and then I saw her twice over
Zoom one was in January 2021 and
new approach okay
Dr Korea in answering that question were
you Consulting anything Dr Hughes doctor
I'm so sorry
uh Dr Hughes were you Consulting
anything Dr Cruz here I guess as well
um I'm concerned in my cheat sheet of
the dates that I saw Miss heard so that
I could accurately um report to the
court I also have my final designation
in front of me so that I could give the
most accurate information to what I put
in that report okay okay and do you want
to see that
okay should we just take the break now
and have him look at it would you like
to look at now or before Crossing it's
just to post it
okay before Crossing okay all right
that's fine thank you
okay
um please continue I think you were
telling us when you saw him as heard
sure
um so the four dates uh in person in New
York City uh for a total of about 21.5
hours and then I saw her
um in January 18 2021 over Zoom for
three hours and then December 27th 2021
uh for four hours over Zoom
and what did the evaluation consist of
so as I stated the evaluation consisted
of psychological testing a
semi-structured clinical interview with
Miss heard a review of a whole host of
documents relative to this case and
medical records and psychological
records and then three collateral
interviews two with her treating
therapist Dr Bonnie Jacobs Dr Connell
Cohen and also with her mom
and in the semi-structured clinical
interview what were you assessing
well when someone comes in for the
evaluation you sometimes don't know what
you're going to see or what you're going
to get so you absolutely have to do a
full clinical interview and have a sense
of their life their life patterns things
that have affected them in their lives
you know where they have worked where
they have lived just get a full sense of
their
um their sort of being before the
incident for which they're talking about
then I do a full intimate partner
violence assessment looking at all those
characteristics that I talked to you
about earlier to get a sense of the full
structure of and the dynamic of this
relationship I also did looking at what
were the effects what were the
psychological consequences of being in
that relationship and I also looked at
the psychological consequences of some
of the statements that were made by Mr
Depp through his attorney that are part
of this the counter claim in this
lawsuit
at the end of that process considering
all the data did you arrive at any
expert opinions yes I did all right I'm
going I'd like to start with your main
expert opinions and then go through
those can you please tell the jury what
your main opinions were
um so like I said there are opinions
embedded within them but the main
opinion is that Miss herd's report of
intimate partner violence and the
records that I reviewed is consistent
with what we know in the field about
intimate partner violence characterized
by physical violence psychological
aggression sexual violence coercive
control and surveillance behaviors
and what was the other uh main opinion
that you had
um the second main opinion was that
um that miss her demonstrated very clear
psychological and traumatic effects or
the exacerbation of Trauma from those
statements that Mr debt made through his
attorney there were three statements
that we evaluated to see how they
affected her emotionally and
psychologically and it was in my
determination that they did
and did you arrive at any diagnostic
conclusions yes I did and what were
those I diagnosed misheard with
post-traumatic stress disorder
uh and what if any etiology was
associated with the post-traumatic
stress disorder so the etiology is the
cause in order to have a to meet
criteria for post-traumatic stress
disorder you have to have an actual
cause it's one of the few diagnoses
diagnostic entities that we have to have
a cause for and the cause was the
intimate partner violence by Mr Depp
that was the what was pushing the
symptoms that was what's related to the
intrusive phenomena that was related to
her avoidance that was elated to her
differences in her mood that was related
to her avoidance efforts so it was the
the cause was the intimate partner
violence by Mr Depp
now let's first go back to the forensic
evaluation you mentioned you reviewed
documents what documents did you review
so I'm going to refer to my list of
documents so that I can be clear for you
all
um it is a four page all right if you
want to approach
Dr Curry
um if if you I mean Dr Hughes I don't
know why my apologies my apologies Dr
Hughes foreign
of having her in the courtroom
um Dr Hughes uh if um if you need to
consult your notes to answer something
let us know that you need to consult
your notes
um otherwise try to answer to the best
of your ability and then if if you need
to do that just let us know your
Consulting your notes okay the concern
is uh that you not read from them that
you consult them as you need to okay
correct I just don't want this to be a
memory test of having conducted many
documents 80 pages of notes but you talk
of psychological testings to you can
reference your notes just don't read
from them okay yeah no problem okay okay
great
so please tell us what documents you
review please tell the jury
okay so I reviewed a number of documents
a plethora of documents um most and I
obviously won't read them all um but I
reviewed certainly all of um Miss
heard's testimony that she gave in her
deposition testimony her deposition
testimony in this case or deposition or
her trial testimony in the UK case I did
the same thing from Mr Depp I reviewed
his deposition testimony as well as his
trial testimony in the UK as well I
reviewed a number of the depositions
that were put forth in this case I
reviewed the psychological treatment
notes for Dr Bonnie Jacobs Dr Connell
Cohen Dr Laurel Anderson and Dr Amy
Banks although she did not have
treatment records so I reviewed not only
their records did collateral interviews
with some of them and also read their
deposition testimony and also read other
medical records in this case nursing
notes in this case
and the highlights and I also listen to
um the audios that were put forth in
this case and read the text messages and
emails
and what if anything did you do with
respect to any videos and I also saw um
the video in the kitchen yes okay
now
the collateral interviews that you
conducted why did you conduct those
well collateral interviews is a standard
part of a forensic evaluation it's an
opportunity to hear from another
treating clinician the person who's
actually treating the individual you're
evaluating and get a better sense from
that person of what they saw what they
knew how they experienced this person
sometimes our clinical notes don't give
the full breadth of what really was
going on in that therapy because the
notes are meant to be sort of shortened
to the point of what was what happened
who was there and what was the plan so
it was really helpful to talk to these
two clinicians who really were with
misheard throughout the duration of her
relationship with Mr Depp so they give
us sort of a contemporaneous look at
what was going on for her emotionally
and then what was she reporting what was
she saying about the relationship to her
therapist
and and you mentioned the name Dr Bonnie
Jacobs please tell the jury who Dr
Bonnie Jacobs is so Dr Bonnie Jacobs was
um Miss heard's therapist and
may I refresh my recollection with my
notes your honor
she's allowed to foreign
yes you may consult your notes yes
objection you are
yeah
can we be here
go ahead go ahead oh thank you
um
so she treated with Dr Bonnie Jacobs who
was a psychologist from October 2011
um through August 2014. um she actually
was seeing miss Dr Jacob somewhat
earlier before she got in the
relationship with Mr Depp and then she
transferred care to Dr Connell Cohen who
was referred by Dr Kipper who was the
treating physician for Mr Depp and then
later for Miss heard and she treated
with Dr Cohen from after she left Dr
Bonnie Jacobs in September 2014 to June
7th 2016. okay thank you
um and so you could and I guess you got
ahead of me there so you also talked to
Dr Cohen correct that's correct okay and
you also spoke with Paige Hurd did you
say that's correct and who is Paige
heard page heard is Amber heard's mother
and when did you speak with Paige Hurd
I spoke with all of these individuals at
the end of 2019 again I can check my
notes and let you know the exact date if
you'd like I think the end of 19.
because they all were in the end of 19.
yes all right and you are you aware that
Paige Hurd has has since died she died
two years ago yes I am aware sadly okay
now let's talk about the psychological
testing you stated that you conducted
psychological testing is that correct
that is correct
can you
overrule that can you please tell uh
tell the jury how many psychological
assessments you administered to Amber
Heard I administered 12.
can you please tell them tell the jury
what which ones you administered
so I am going to refer to my designation
that has the list so that I don't forget
anything okay
so I administered um objection here say
your honor she can refresh her
recollection as long as she's not
reading it right you just can't read
that you're not supposed to read from it
but you can refresh your recollection as
you're speaking
so I can look and just look up and
that's refreshing my recollection
okay all right if we could approach for
a moment
foreign
foreign
Dr Hughes can you tell the jury the
tests that you administered please yes I
can
um I administered the personality
assessment inventory which is a
Broadband uh instrument to scan for
Psychopathology and psychological
symptoms that people have I administered
the trauma symptom inventory 2 which is
an instrument to scan for common
traumatic effects that people have I
administered the Miller forensic
assessment of symptoms test which is a
measure of malingering I administered
the post-traumatic stress disorder
checklist for the fifth edition for the
DSM-5 I administered the clinician
administered PTSD scale for DSM-5
I administered the back depression
inventory the back anxiety inventory the
mood disorders questionnaire
the danger I did three uh intimate
partner violence measures the conflict
tactic scale the abusive Behavior
observation checklist and the danger
assessment scale and then I also did the
life events checklist which scans and
gets us to ask about a lot of traumatic
events that an individual may have
experienced and we administer that
typically before either doing the PCL or
doing the caps
thank you were there any tests you
administered to Amber Heard that were
designed to reveal malingering or
feigning yes they were okay can you
please tell the jury about those so
malingering is the false production of
psychological symptomatology for the
purpose of some external material gain
feigning is uh the false production of
psychological symptomatology but with no
identification of what that gain may be
so basically fainting is saying your
mental health is worse than it actually
is so I administered three of the tests
had validity indices built in that could
allow us to address that question the M
fast the Miller assessment a forensic
assessment of symptoms test is a
specific malingering instrument it looks
at malingering Psychopathology is this
someone you know malingering
Psychopathology she scored a zero on
that scale um so on that on that test
sorry not the scale that test I'm so on
that test there was no evidence of
malingering
on the TSI there are two validity
indices and she scored within the normal
range on those scores as well one was
slightly elevated but when in testing
the limits because it has rare symptoms
and uh over endure symptoms
um I determined that that also was a
valid measure and then finally the Pai
the large-scale 344 question instrument
has very robust validity scales on it to
test for exaggeration or feigning or
malingering and she did not score in any
of those scores and those scales at all
those were not elevated so the combined
results between those three tests
suggests to me that Miss herd is not
malingering her psychological
symptomatology
now Dr Curry testified that one test
showed quote intentional exaggeration in
the 98th percentile meaning that she
engaged in extreme levels of
exaggeration end of quote do you agree
with that I do not why
because that test the scale that she is
referring to is the it's called ATR it's
the atypical response scale as I said
that combines rare symptoms and over-end
door symptoms it's very frequently
elevated in people who have high levels
of distress and then importantly on this
test specifically it says do not use the
percentile rank it is in the manual it
is in italices because the way that this
test was normed it was normed on people
who have trauma so it's what we call
negatively skewed that means it falls on
the tail end of the Continuum it is not
a normal curve where we would normal
think normally think of how a percentile
would work so you would not use the
percentile rank on this test
community
you want to approach yes please okay
Dr Hughes please continue
um so that is a very inaccurate way to
describe that scale and that test
um and so the ATR scale on this test is
probably the least robust of our
validity scale so you would never make a
comment like that based on one scale if
you don't have consistency across data
and when you look at the consistency
across the testing with the Pai the TSI
and the M fast and this research to
support that that when they go together
you have a higher degree of likelihood
that this is not feigned PTSD that this
is not feigned symptomatology and then
actually if I look at the validity
scores on the mmpi2 that Dr Curry
administered those scales are not
elevated for exaggeration or malingering
either so if I add that now I have
really robust data that Miss road is not
malingering or feigning her
psychological symptomatology
thank you did you administer any tests
that are specific to domestic violence
yes I did which ones so that was the
conflict tactic scale the abusive
Behavior observation checklist and the
danger assessment scale and what did
they show
I would like to refer to the testing
to refresh to refresh my recollection
just a glance on yes you may do that
clear with
the jury
so what the um overall gist of the
testing was was that
um and the benefit of these tests is
that they allow me to ask for what Mr
Depp did to misheard and then also what
misheard did to miss the death so it was
asking about both sets of behavior
um and One Direction your honor
we're back to reading
she wasn't even looking down she was
looking at the jury
go go ahead please please continue so
what these tests show was that there was
a high degree of
um serious violence perpetrated by Mr
debt toward misheard there was violence
more on the mild level perpetrated by
misheard toward Mr Depp with one severe
indicator which was the punching that
she indicated to me
there were scales about negotiation
about how much this couple tries to
figure out their problems they both
scored again this is Miss heard
reporting that but they both scored in
the high range where they're both saying
that yes we're trying to figure this out
we're trying to work out this
relationship there were scores on the
psychological aggression scale where
um Miss uh Mr Depp engaged in more
severe acts of psychological aggression
whereas miss her did engage in also some
mild and severe acts of psychological
aggression the amount of injury that was
reported was significantly higher and
more severe by misheard what she was
subjected to and then she was subjected
to sexual violence where Mr Depp based
on her report was subjected to none
and then the other on the danger
assessment scale that there were a
number of factors that were related to
severity
in in violent relationships and a risk
factor when we look as I said earlier
when behaviors come up on this scale
they're very worrisome very scary and we
have to take them seriously so there
were a number of behaviors that came up
on this scale such as Mr debbs threatens
to kill her the increase in severity of
the abuse the forced sexual activity the
choking Behavior his obsessive jealousy
objection Foundation
talking about the test results
go ahead please continue the obsessive
jealousy the control aspect and his
um threatening of suicide to kill
himself so those were risk factors
um that placed her in the increased
danger range and this is a a range that
you know says that we certainly have to
advise women of their risk and consult
with
law enforcement if they're involved or
judges if they're involved because this
means that a woman is at risk for more
serious or lethal domestic violence
so did the results of the psychological
tests you administered to Amber Heard
supported diagnosis of PTSD objection
leading
what if any psychological tests did you
administer that supported a diagnosis of
PTSD for Amber Heard sure so um there
were four tests that supported that
diagnosis one was the Pai which was that
344 question large scale personality
inventory
on that test her largest subscale her
her highest subscale was the one that
measures dramatic stress so that was
clinically significant on the TSI two of
her scales were the intrusive
experiences Dimension and the defensive
avoidance Dimension two of the classic
scales of trauma and PTSD on the PCL
which is the post-traumatic stress
disorder checklist five
that she scored in all four domains of
PTSD and that's an instrument that says
how much how much are you bothered by
these symptoms and in all four clusters
which would be the intrusive
experiencing when things about the abuse
of the trauma enter your mind when you
did not want to want them to sometimes
they're cued sometimes they're uncued
she answered in the avoidance category
which is a second category of PTSD that
I do things to try not to think about
this to try not to feel this to try not
to get upset sometimes I avoid certain
people because they become a trigger for
me she scored in the what we call the
negative alterations in cognition and
mood changes in her thoughts and
feelings as a result of the abuse and
Trauma and also in the physiological
hyperactivity the hyperarousal the hyper
vigilance this thought or response so on
the PCL she endorsed symptoms in all
four of those categories saying you know
some of these symptoms are bothering me
a lot and then finally the clinician
administered uh
PTSD scale for the DSM-5 and what that
allows me to do unlike the PCL is really
look at symptom severity and and symptom
for frequency how is this really playing
out for this individual and similarly
she scored in all four categories of um
of trauma and of having intrusive
experiences and Nightmares and avoidance
efforts and physiological hyperactivity
and changes in her mood and her thoughts
and her total score was a 28 which falls
in the moderate range so that means that
she has experiencing a moderate degree
of post-traumatic stress disorder
symptomatology and those tests allow me
to make that definitive diagnosis that
she suffers from PTSD
thank you what if any consideration did
you give to Amber heard's history of
childhood abuse in making your diagnosis
I mean that was a significant
consideration given that we know that
childhood well first of all we know that
people can experience multiple traumas
across the lifespan and we wanted to
make sure that the symptoms that she was
experiencing were related to what she
experienced with Mr Depp and not her
childhood and certainly you know earlier
on in the evaluation and when I
evaluated and spoke with her that was
true and that was also true on the
latest measure the clinician
administered PTSD scale for DSM-5 the
Caps V and that's because the content
you have to look at what is the content
of the symptoms so it's not that someone
says oh yeah something traumatic comes
into my mind no what is it what comes
into your mind what bothers you what are
the triggers and those were all specific
to miss heard's relationship with Mr
death the reason the childhood is also
significant is that we know that if
somebody suffers childhood abuse as a
child they are much more likely to have
an adult re-victimization and they're
much more likely than to be more
vulnerable to obtaining a PTSD to
getting PTSD if they've had that prior
vulnerability so it's a very strong
vulnerability characteristic to
obtaining PTSD when you have a
subsequent trauma
the other aspect about her childhood
abuse is that she was raised in a family
of violence she was physically abused by
her father she saw her father abuse her
mother her father was very explosive and
had violent outbursts and both her
parents also struggled with substance
abuse very significantly so she had
learned from a very early age how to
caretake how to live in a situation that
is mired in chaos how do I take care of
a parent who's passed out nodded out
from heroin and how do I get up and get
my sister to school she learned at a
very early age that she had to figure
out how to do this in this scenario and
I would say lastly what that environment
taught her was that she learned that she
could love someone who hurts her
she knew that people who hurt her also
can love her and she learned how to have
this tolerance for cognitive
inconsistency this tolerance for two
should be diametrically opposed emotions
but she grew up knowing or believing
perhaps that this could happen and she
also believed that she could fix him
just like she tried to fix her father
and just like she tried to fix her
mother she truly truly believed that she
could fix Mr Depp and rid him of his
substance abuse problems
but that did not work
did you review Dr Curry's caps five that
she administered to Amber Heard yes I
did
um and what if any agreement did you
have with Dr Curry's interpretation of
the Caps five
um I didn't agree with her
interpretation having been a trauma
psychologist for over 25 years and
administered hundreds of these I found
that there were flaws in how she chose
to administer it and then some of the
coding
misheard on that caps five to Dr Kari
certainly reported trauma-based
symptomatology related to the abuse by
Mr debt but somehow that was not coded
as such
and
did you review Dr Curry's mmpi too that
she administered on Amber Heard um yes I
did and do you agree with her
interpretations on that test no I do not
why not
because this profile is a normal profile
it is there are no clinical scores
elevated above 65 which is one and a
half standard deviations of the mean
which is what we use to determine
clinical significance and if none of
those scales are elevated it becomes
very difficult for us to make
assumptions about a person's psychology
and their functioning now remember the
psychological testing generates
hypothesis about a person that we then
using our clinical judgment have to make
a decision about we have to make an
assessment about it and if none of those
scales are elevated it just doesn't give
us rich information to make those
determinations the one scale which is
accurate that was elevated was one that
measures defensive responding sort of a
protective responding an unwillingness
to admit minor fault that was elevated
and that was true but the result of that
is you have a defensive profile you have
somebody who's not giving you a lot of
information so the scales are all low so
there's no way you can take that mmpi
and then say it meets uh it's consistent
with borderline personality disorder you
just don't have the symptom expression
on it in order to do that
and that's my next question here what if
any diagnoses did you make of
personality disorders for Amber Heard
based on your testing I did not make a
personality disorder of Miss Earth why
not
for a number of reasons um number one a
personality disorder requires a
pervasive pattern in a variety of
contexts two keywords pervasive pattern
variety of contexts that means if her
emotional instability her affect
dysregulation or her fear of Abandonment
is only occurring in the relationship
with Mr Depp and we don't have evidence
of it before and we don't have evidence
of it after it is not or approach
foreign
foreign
thank you
all right
Dr Hughes
um
did what if anything did Dr Cowan say to
you about any type of diagnoses of
personality disorders
Dr Cohen did not diagnose misheard with
any personality disorder and what if
anything to Dr Bonnie Jacobs say about
diagnosing Amber Heard with any
personality disorders and and Dr Jacob
similarly did not diagnose misheard with
any personality disorder thank you
now let's turn back to intimate partner
violence what types of physical violence
were reported to you
um so there were a number of physically
violent behaviors that were reported
um that Mr reported that Mr Depp
perpetrated
um he pushed her he shoved her he
slapped her with the front of his hand
and the back of his hand he choked her
he slammed her into the wall he pushed
her and she fell down he kicked her in
the back
um
again without looking at my notes that's
the what I can recall okay and what type
of injuries did Amber Heard report to
you she reported mostly
um bruising pain Some Cuts she reported
vaginal pain from some of the sexual
assaults she reported that she did have
some scratches and cuts on her from
broken glass she reported that she
believed she may have lost Consciousness
two times once in the Australia incident
and once in the December 15th 2015
incident
what type of coercive control did was
recorded or did you find
leading
what if any uh
coercive control uh was reported to you
so the course of control that um was
determined in this relationship I found
to be quite significant there were many
many instances where Mr debb tried to
control how misheard went about her
career he didn't want her to show nudity
he didn't want her to show boob he
didn't want her to act with certain
actors because of this obsessive
jealousy he criticized her ambition he'd
rather she not work he called you know
the ambition is something as a negative
thing it made her very fearful to have
to look at scripts or talk about scripts
or talk about movie roles because he
persistently put those down and told her
she didn't need to work and she didn't
need to do that and she didn't need to
show her tits and ass he didn't
necessarily support her work the way
this manifested as well is that he
called almost every actor that she had
to work with
um males and females so no matter what
show she was filming or shooting he
would call the leading actor he would
call the director he would tell you I
got eyes down there I got eyes down on
the set
um so she never felt safe to be herself
and be an actress in these films or
Productions because she'd have to come
home and then endure his anger at her
for doing something or for not doing
something when she was filming and he
was in the same town she feared that he
would show up on the set and you know to
know what her call she what she was
filming that day she you know even told
her assistant don't give it to him don't
let him see it so that he won't show up
and sometimes he did so it was very uh
trepidatious for her and very anxiety
provoking that he continued to do this
he tried to control what she wore when
he when she was going out with him
things were fine but he told her often
no woman like mine is going to dress
like a [ __ ]
um and didn't want her to wear revealing
clothing
um and or revealing clothing according
to him she recalled an incident when she
was going on a job audition and he said
you know you're going to go out with
those tits and ass you know and she had
to sort of go in and and put on what she
said mom jeans so that she didn't look
sexy so she didn't look revealing and
continue to try to plead with him about
what jobs she could take and she could
not take this made her be very sort of
restrictive and try to conceal things
she would hide her scripts because she
couldn't read them in front of him
because he would put them down or want
to see where there might be nudity where
there might be something where she's
doing a love scene and then every almost
every person that she was in a film with
there would be those barrages of the
consistent accusations of infidelity and
we saw that on the Australia pictures
the Billy Bob he was one person that he
continued you know to
berate her about having an affair with
that's what obsessive control looks like
those messages on the mirror when you
look at how he wanted her to um be there
was some interference with with the
family with her with her sister when her
when some things were leaked you know he
was obsessed believing that it was
Whitney who did it and and eventually
Miss heard had to succumb and say okay
yes it was and then alienate herself
from her sister because she just
couldn't take the fights anymore she
just couldn't take the constant barrage
of criticism so there are many instances
when
um in terms of their interactions of she
would have to text him right back but
when he would text when she would text
him he could not answer for days
um and it's this sort of where we talk
about you know the ghosting but you your
husband doesn't ghost you your partner
doesn't ghost you um and there were so
many times of this sort of withdrawal of
affection which was on his terms and
when he wanted to do it
um I'm aware that there is you know
testimony in this case that you know Mr
Depp decided to leave because he didn't
want to be violent and I do think that's
true sometimes I think he did leave in
times where he didn't want an
altercation he did leave after an
altercation he did leave and then came
back and continued the altercation so
leaving wasn't the defining variable the
problem was that you know with this
obsessiveness and this perseveration
that he had the fight would always come
back so leaving might end the argument
for that moment but miss heard no he was
always going to come back and he was
going to you know start the
interrogation once again
and what is the effect of the coercive
control on Amber Heard
I mean the effect was drastic she talked
to me that she you know her roles
consistently dropped over the time that
she was in the relationship with Mr Depp
just because it was so difficult to to
go on auditions to to want to be in in a
different location with him whenever she
was not on location
um with him it was very stressful it was
very anxiety provoking because of the
accusations of infidelity we heard that
through Isaac baruch's testimony when
she called and was saying babe there's
no one here there's no one here that was
something that she had to do repeatedly
and constantly over the course of the
relationship so it caused a significant
amount of anxiety of distress of of
having to try to conceal and maneuver
around him to to try to have the career
that she wanted to have it made her
hyper Vigilant and definitely
contributed to sort of her psychological
symptomatology getting worse over time
what about sexual violence
so there was a number of incidents of
sexual violence reported um in this
relationship
um those are documented early on in Dr
Bonnie Jacob's notes
um where when Mr Depp was drunk or high
he threw her on the bed ripped off her
nightgown and tried to have sex with her
there were times when he forced her to
give him oral sex when he was angry
these weren't in in loving moments these
were angry moments and moments of
dominance moments of him trying to get
control over her there was a time when
they were in Hicksville and in in the
trailer I want to say trailer park but I
guess there's trailer park
it is a Trello Park where he was
accusing her of of a woman hitting on
Amber and that that was the problem
amber
um got accused of women hitting on her
and it got accused of men hitting on us
so there was there were so many targets
that um came through in his obsessive
jealousy but when he um on that incident
when Kelly Sue
um was accused of hitting on misheard
and they went back into the trailer Mr
Depp performed a cavity search and
ostensibly was looking for drugs and
felt it acceptable to rip off her Nikon
and and stick his fingers up her vagina
to look for cocaine thought that maybe
she was hiding them there and again
these incidents often happened in a
drug-fueled rage there was another
incident in the Bahamas where when he
got angry he took his fingers and he put
him in her vagina and moved her around
violently in the closet again in an act
of sexual violence
and of course the incident in Australia
was one of the most severe instances of
sexual violence that misheard had to
endure in which when he was beating her
and choking her and telling her I'm
going to [ __ ] kill you I hate you I
hate you I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you when
he grabs a bottle that was on the bar
and penetrated her with that bottle and
miss her reported to me of of
dissociating and going outside of her
body and the only thing she was thinking
is oh God I hope it's not the broken one
what if any psychological abuse did you
find
there was a number of psychologically
abusive behaviors as I stated
um you know misheard admitted to me and
reported that she engaged in those
behaviors as well she reported that she
um did call him names and offensive
comments and said things to him that
were horrible and that she was
incredibly saddened and horrified by her
behavior and looking back she at this
point not being in the constant barrage
of abuse does not recognize her
the abuse by Mr Depp he called her a
number of names
frequently horror [ __ ] [ __ ] lesbian camp
counselor
um you know easy ambition ambition was a
weaponized term in that relationship so
he called her a lot of names and and
humiliated her and of course I think we
talked about the intimidation tactics
that you know Mr Depp was often banging
and throwing and hitting things I'm in
the household which sort of got the
tension to
um rise up very significantly very
quickly
can you tell me how you conducted your
analysis to arrive at these conclusions
sure so what I I did was look at the
incidents that were reported and look at
the corroborating data around it so as
we stated most of these
incidents of intimate partner violence
happen behind closed doors not everyone
is going to witness what the parties are
reporting behind closed doors so you
look at what is the what is the data
that surrounds it isn't there any data
before it is there any data after it is
the person telling is the victims
telling somebody in real time about
what's happening are there therapy notes
are there pictures or their text
messages that sort of allow us to fill
in the pieces of the picture even though
we don't have exactly what happened at
that moment the more collateral that we
have and the consistency across those
data points it gives us greater
confidence in our results
can can you give us some examples
um sure so
vague
so um for example the Boston plane
incident I believe without looking I
know May 24 2014 this is the incident
where
um misheard and Mr Depp were going to
fly back to LA and spend the weekend
together they were shooting at different
sites
um Miss hurt is on the plane waiting for
Mr Depp to come on and the tarmac he's
reportedly sitting on the in the SUV
smoking and drinking smoking weed and
drinking she is filming with James
Franco at this point and she gets on the
plane and he starts talking about James
Franco
um you know making a lot of um uh
derogatory comments about her and um you
know I hope you had fun with your
escapades and and some more um
inflammatory language and then in an
argument when she got up to leave he
kicked her in the back and she went
forward on the plane
um to the front of the plane because he
sat in the back of the plane so if I
look at what is the corresponding data
to this there's a therapy note several
notes in Bonnie Jacobs records that talk
about
Mr Depp's increasing use of alcohol
and his obsessive jealousy around James
Franco
before this Boston plain Epson after the
incident Miss heard told her friend IO
she told a friend Savannah she told her
friend Rocky Miss Hurd did not go home
she was afraid to go home so she went to
a hotel because when Johnny was in these
states he would often show up because
he's still in that drinking and drugging
phase and he talked about that that was
the roxycodone before he detoxed you
know he was still in that you know High
substance abuse phase that he would
often show up at night and that did not
feel safe
there was a text from Stephen dutors Mr
Depp's assistant
all right you want to approach
foreign
all right so
Dr Hughes look
let's go past that text and talk about
um
go past that text and continue after
that text
um sure so there was
um Mr dapp apologized to miss her for
that incident
um Mr debb said in his UK testimony well
I only maybe playfully tapped her on the
back with my foot
um Mr Depp texted Paul Bettany and
talked about how he was so drunk and out
of control and engaged in bad behavior
he texted his friend Patty Smith a very
similar type of text about how drunk and
out of control he was and then finally
Amber Heard wrote an email
talking about how distressed and
heartbroken she was objection hearsay
I I I mean I don't agree
sustain I'll sustain the objection next
question all right
can you give can you give another
example
I I think those are all I can um
remember at this point okay
um
what if any uh
what if any
um
sorry I'm gonna have to go a little bit
further here so you concluded that Amber
Heard use psychological abuse and some
reactive physical violence I think I
heard you say is that correct objection
leading overruled
can you please explain to the jury what
you meant by that yes that is correct
that um you know Amber Heard reported to
me
um some of the behaviors that she used
that were psychologically aggressive
um the name calling the putting him down
and calling him
um very bad names and insulting his his
fatherhood and she was very shamed and
remorseful about that she also indicated
you know using and as some of the
testing showed minor forms of violence
pushing shoving
um throwing objects we see that a lot
with um women when there's not
proportional Force women are more likely
to throw objects and then the more
severe Act of of punching him which a
punch falls in the more severe category
and and the context as she explained it
was that he was coming after Whitney and
she stood her sister and she stood in
the way and she punched him
no
does that make Amber Heard a perpetrator
of intimate partner violence objection
leading
overruled so so that was one of the
tasks that I had to consider that was
one of the hypotheses that I had to
consider and given all of the other data
that was not my opinion
okay thank you now you stated that you
read a number of therapy records please
tell the jury why are therapy records
important
therapy records are critical for a
forensic psychologist when we have the
opportunity to go back in time and see
what a person was dealing with what the
content of their distress was and what
the symptoms of their distress was it
really gives us a snapshot in time so
they become very critical as part of the
overall forensic psychological
evaluation because we as psychologists
understand how people sort of treat in
therapy and what to look for so in
looking back at Miss heard's therapy
records we see sort of real time
unfolding of this dynamic in this
relationship we see early on in her
notes with in her report with Bonnie
Jacobson and Dr Bonnie Jacobs notes
reports of constant concerns about Mr
Depp's substance abuse constant concerns
about him passing out and vomiting
constant concerns about not the
objection your honor hearsay
she can characterize that and say she
would write on that overruled thank you
please continue constant concerns about
how do I get him into treatment how do I
get him help
um Miss heard starts going to Al-Anon at
this point early 2012 and the beginning
of the relationship because she has to
figure out and wants to figure out a way
to support the man that she's dating
right now and the man who she's falling
madly in love with the reports in Dr
Jacob's notes early on about his
controlling Behavior about his jealousy
Behavior about him not of not wanting to
do certain jobs of not wanting her to
wear certain clothes so this is going
back to 2012.
um with no indication of why would she
be saying that but for the sole purpose
of trying to get help and trying to get
guidance in this relationship that she
finds so difficult there are indications
as I mentioned before of the sexual
assault and the sexual abuse and and how
he would you know when he was angry and
when he was drunk it was mostly drug and
and your alcohol fueled rage when he
would you know throw her on the bed and
try to have sex with her and then you
know if he was not able to perform he
would get more angry at her and blame
her so we have this Dynamic of blaming
her for his inability to take
responsibility for his behavior those
themes were throughout Dr Jacob's notes
did
um
did Dr Jacobs assign any diagnoses to
Amber Heard she did early on she
diagnosed her with panic disorder and
then later with post-traumatic stress
disorder
and did Dr Jacobs diagnose and Amber
Heard with borderline personality
disorder no she did not
histrionic personality disorder no she
did not
and is that important
that's very important when we're trying
to figure out the course of somebody's
illness the course of somebody's
psychiatric difficulties as I stated
well I don't think I got to State
personality disorders usually start in
adolescence earlier objection
I'll sustain the objection next question
okay
um
you also stated that you reviewed Dr
Colonel Cowan's treatment notes correct
correct and you also read his deposition
testimony correct and you had a
how long of a collateral interview with
him I believe it was two hours okay and
what what did you get from from all of
that data
so by the time that she gets to a doctor
Connell Cohen which is 2014 I believe
September 2014 is when Dr Kipper comes
on the scene misheards psychological
functioning is is significantly
deteriorated She's suffering more
anxiety more sleeplessness more
agitation more emotional dysregulation
this fluctuation in moods and when you
sort of look at the records of what
happened in those first two years from
Dr Jacobs and now we have up to Dr
O'Connell Cohen and we see all of the
incidents that she was exposed to
including the sexual violence and the
coercive control it makes sense to me
that her status her psychological
functioning has deteriorated and in Dr
Cohen's notes that's what he's
always trying to do is trying to help
her
help Mr Depp help her act in a way so
that Mr Depp does not hurt her
um Mr Depp I mean pardon me Dr Connell
Cohen was very concerned for uh Amber
Heard safety as was Dr Bonnie Jacobs Dr
Jacobs was very concerned for her safety
and she continued to talk about safety
aspects for Miss heard as was Connell
Cohen
um you know they did both of them both
therapists understood and misheard
talked to them about it that there were
times that she fought back and she used
violence in times that she screamed and
she said things that she didn't want to
but nevertheless that did not change the
balance for them either and they were
very concerned that because of Mr Depp's
significant substance abuse and his sort
of poorly controlled anger that at some
point he was going to seriously hurt her
did Dr Cohen provide Ms heard with the
diagnosis of borderline personality
disorder
no he did not did he diagnose Amber
Heard with histrionic personality
disorder no he did not is that important
it's important that you are have a an
individual misheard who's in therapy for
over two years with one therapist and
over two years with another therapist
and you're not seeing those
characteristics of a personality
disorder if if the the manifestation of
a person's difficulties and illness and
symptomatology is better explained by
another disorder then you don't qualify
for the personality disorder you can't
get the diagnosis I mean that's part of
the criteria so if it's not a pervasive
pattern a variety of contexts and it
can't be better explained by her trauma
experience and the exposure and the
symptoms as a result of that trauma then
you don't get a personality disorder and
that's why they didn't diagnose it
did you read Dr Amy Banks deposition
testimony yes I did and what were her
findings
so she Dr Banks had one session
um one couple session with Mr Depp and
misheard
um Dr Banks is
um very reputable she works up at the
Harvard Medical School Cambridge victim
the violence program which is a very
well-known program for understanding
um the objection your honor what's the
objection
it's non-responsive to the question the
question was what was the findings all
right
tell us tell the jury who Dr Amy Banks
is
and just like I said so she's somebody
who has um a wealth of experience in
understanding intimate partner violence
and the Dynamics of of violent
relationships but she only had one
session with the couple
um and it was her determination when
they were both there and the violence
was talked about that Mr dub did not to
Die the violence that he um perpetrated
toward misheard
um she also did as everybody has all of
our other therapists because Miss heard
admitted as such that she also used low
levels of violence as well so um Dr Amy
Banks had that opinion
did you review Dr Laurel Anderson's
treatment notes and read her deposition
oh yes I did okay and what was the
significance of what you learned from Dr
Anderson so Dr Anderson similarly
thought that there was violence and
abuse in this relationship she was the
one therapist out of the four who
qualified it as Mutual abuse
um which um the termination I've talked
to you about I don't necessarily agree
with but she did see and did understand
that there was violence and abuse by Mr
doe what was most notable was that after
the December 15
2015 episode Mr Coulter in addition to
calling Connell Cohen and reached out to
a number of people but she saw Dr
Anderson in her office and Dr Anderson
store two bruises on her face and told
me my husband kicked me and he pushed me
and he punched me in the head and should
I call the police
I she's not reading your honor she's
just saying to the significance sustain
the objection next question
all right what were your uh what
conclusions did you make as a result of
Dr what you reviewed for Dr Laurel
Anderson
my take of reading Dr Laurel Anderson's
deposition and seeing her you know
redacted notes was that you know
from my professional opinion this was a
very serious
incident and a very serious allegation
of intimate partner violence by Mr Depp
if a patient comes into my office with
two bruises and alleges being pushed
shoved and kicked by her partner I'm
going to be very concerned that I'm
going to mobilize a lot more resources
to help that individual and for some
reason
that did not happen for Miss heard
through your overall clinical
Impressions from reading these notes
from Amber heard's treatment providers
and their couple's therapy therapists
objection compound
aren't sustained
what are your overall clinical
Impressions from reading what you told
everybody you bet
objection compound
I mean I don't know how to get a less
compound your overall go ahead thank you
full impression of
notes was you know there's significant
support for the fact that there was
intimate partner violence in this
relationship it was consistently
reported over time and there were
couples therapists who saw and
understood that
um so you know there were uh Mr Depp
also attended a session with Dr Connell
Cohen with misheard and in that session
he was very belligerent and mean and
yelling and intimidating and even got up
and stormed out
roll the joint and then came back later
Dr Connell Cohen's impression was this
is somebody who's poorly controlled
that's the same thing that Dr Laurel
Anderson said about him and he stormed
out of one of those sessions too so
there were a total of six sessions
couple session but Mr depth stormed out
of two of them so only four couple
sessions for these two individuals in
this just highly volatile highly
damaging relationship that was you know
punctuated by the coercive control and
the intimate partner violence
what if any observations did you make
about Amber heard's psychological status
over the that period
I mean the record was very clear that
her psychological status deteriorated as
she was in the relationship with Mr
death she kept getting worse she was
losing weight she by the end she was
down to it I think 105 pounds from about
125 130. she was taking significantly
more medication than she's ever taken in
her life she was having more Panic more
anxiety more distress more affect
dysregulation just really an inability
to regulate her mood more anger Outburst
so it can significantly deteriorate over
time
you talked about weight what if any
diagnoses did
um Bonnie Jacobs make about Amber Heard
having an eating disorder
there was no evidence in the record that
misheard had an eating disorder what if
any observations did you make about
whether Dr Cowan Connell thought she had
an eating disorder there was no
indication in his record that she had an
eating disorder
now what if any
observations did you make about
uh the impact of Mr debb substance abuse
so the substance abuse was a very
relevant and and complicating factor to
this relationship when you pair that
level of substance abuse with the level
of intimate partner violence and
coercive control it's a very very
disastrous mix and one of the things
that that happens with the substance
abuse is a very similar Dynamic that
happens with the intimate partner
violence that there's there's the lying
there's the hiding there's the cheating
there's the obfuscation you know the
rationalization about the drinking the
rationalization about the violence the
trying to you know promises I'm going to
do better I'm going to get clean and
sober I'm not going to hit you anymore
can I be here everyone approach
foreign
um what if any Dynamics and coping
styles are connected to the substance
abuse by Mr Depp
so they share similarities there's a lot
of lying when somebody's a substance
abuser there's a lot of hiding there's a
lot of concealment there's a lot of
rationalization there's a lot of blame
blaming your partner for your inability
to stay clean and sober there's a lot of
the promises to change and and the
promises to get better so a lot of these
Dynamics sort of co-occur you know in a
situation of of substance abuse and
domestic violence they're very similar
the difficulty in this relationship was
that the majority of the violent
episodes and the sexually violent
episodes were in these alcohol and
drug-fueled rages that was predominantly
when those happened when he wasn't in
those stages we still saw the obsessive
jealousy and the course of control and
the possessiveness that still persisted
but when the alcohol and the drugs came
together is when Amber Heard was more in
in danger of being hurt by him
why didn't Amber Heard leave the
relationship sooner
I mean you know objection speculation
you are
what do you have you formed based on
your experience and based on your 29
hours of
clinical evaluation of Amber Heard what
is your understanding of why Amber Heard
didn't leave the relationship earlier
objection beyond the the scope of the
disclosure
is not I mean it's clearly in the
disclosure
point point to where you say it's not
I mean point to where you say it's not
yeah
foreign
you indicated that your main opinion was
that Amber heard's report of violence
and abuse in her relationship with Mr
Depp is consistent with what is known as
intimate partner violence correct that's
correct okay and and
why did you believe that Amber Heard why
did you have what formed your basis of
that opinion in a nutshell asked an
answer your honor
Dynamics
and not just the hitting and the yelling
but looking at how much more hitting was
done looking at the coercive control the
obsessive jealousy the possessiveness
the sexual violence the choking Behavior
the threats to kill those are all as I
stated very significant and often found
in cases of lethal domestic violence
those were significant severity factors
and looking at all those that's what
tipped the scale that even though she
yelled and said some horrible things and
hit him it never was able to shift the
balance of power and control in that
relationship
now you have discussed with Amber Heard
and you have reviewed and evaluated
um the emotional impact on Amber Heard
as a result of emotional distress as a
result of the three counterclaim
statements correct the the three alleged
defamatory statements made by
Mr Depp through Mr Waldman correct that
is correct okay objection compound
leading
I just overall go ahead thank you thank
you could you please tell the jury what
psychological impact these statements
had on Amber Heard
yes so there were three statements that
I evaluated
um
may I check my notes to give you the
dates and my Recollections so that you
can I can be clear since I couldn't put
it in this might be the fastest way
you're on Earth
my brother should not address the court
I'm sorry I'm sorry yes okay yes
um so there were three statements on
April 8th 2020 April 27 2020 and June 24
2020 that I um queried her about and
asked her about
um the one that um what happens is if
somebody who like Miss heard has
trauma-based symptoms and PTSD we say
that PTSD is a cue based disorder there
are things that happen in the
environment that trigger it and make it
worse and having to have to refute that
your report of violence and abuse is a
hoax makes one be act makes that trauma
activated so it makes the PTSD symptoms
at that time become more intense and
more severe so she would have more
intrusive thoughts more nightmares more
sleeplessness more
difficulty engaging with other people
depression sadness stress all of that
would happen when one of these
statements came out the one that was you
know the most difficult was the one
where they said that her sexual violence
objection was a hoax
what subject
please continue the one that was most
difficult for misheard was the statement
about calling her sexual violence a hoax
as I stated earlier most women try very
diligently to put that sexual violence
in a box bury it down not want to talk
about it not want to you know have
anything related to it come up and you
know she's done you know by my
estimation and her coping although she
suffers from post-traumatic stress
disorder she also has a high degree of
coping strategies but when this would
happen it sort of were just everything
would deteriorate and this is the the
one thing that women have always afraid
of that no one's going to believe them
no one's going to take them seriously
and when somebody comes out in in the
popular media and calls your experience
a hoax that lended itself to more severe
psychological and traumatic
symptomatology for her
Dr Hughes are all of your opinions that
you have provided today within a
reasonable degree of psychological
probability or certainty
yes they are thank you I have no further
questions all right
ladies and gentlemen I think this is a
good time to go ahead and uh break for
the day we can have cross-examination
and redirect tomorrow of this witness of
Dr Hughes so if you could have a a good
evening do not discuss the case with
anybody and uh don't do any outside
research okay we'll see you in the
morning
thank you
okay
all right Dr Hugh since you're still in
the middle of your testimony please
don't discuss your testimony with
anybody including the attorneys okay and
anything that you looked at referenced
during your direct examination if you
could just turn that over so they can
review that before cross-examination
okay
all right thank you man just
presume she wants to be able to take
that back with her we can get copies of
it uh
whatever it is okay I'll we'll make sure
you get copies of it so which you get
copies of it so she can keep her
Originals yes thank you all right
no no no no no no we're not talking
right now thank you all right so
anything else then so we'll see you
tomorrow at 10 A.M correct all right
thank you have a good evening
foreign
thank you
foreign